Yeah,
three,
two,
one.
Is that a,
is that a gun?
That was a weird point.
That was not.
It wasn't sure if that was the gun.
Chris Ryan.
Hey,
I'm good dude.
The Van van anthropology out there,
man.
What do you do to events and I call her.
You just traveling in that thing.
I just got back from a month on the
road.
Yeah.
Wow.
To New Orleans and back.
I was just New Orleans too,
but it only took three hours.
Yeah,
I took the scenic route.
How many days did it take to drive New
Orleans?
Uh,
you know,
we stopped a lot along the way,
but uh,
it's,
I dunno,
10,
12 days or something like that.
You want to stop?
We actually,
we went down along the border.
We,
we were in Bisbee a standard now.
He was in Asia.
He was um,
you know,
Southeast Asia.
It,
like when you think of [inaudible],
you think of Stan up in extra ball at
this point.
It's not much of a reason to go to.
You say you didn't visit standard.
Like if she went to Phoenix and didn't
visit a guy that you knew there,
it's like,
I'm sorry man,
I got really busy.
Yes,
that's normal.
But if you went to Brisbane,
didn't visit Stan Hope.
Yeah.
How many people are in Brisbane?
I don't know,
but there are low.
It's a strange little place if you've
been there.
No scared.
It's like this giant open pit mine and
like the hills are all kind of purple
and weird colors because it's all slag
from the mine.
Really?
Yeah.
It's.
It's a toxic looking place.
I got to say.
I don't know why anyone would choose to
live their real estate crashes.
Dr Chris Ryan Trash has been going down.
I'm not saying anything that isn't
pretty obvious.
If you drive through town,
I'm sure they're a nice parts of town.
I don't know.
We just drove through.
I was.
The coolest thing about this van is I've
combined it with the podcast and so I'm
traveling and I'm also meeting people
along the way.
Some of which are planned,
like if Stan hope had been around and
was willing to hang,
definitely would've hung with them,
but others just come up like,
uh,
right near Bisbee.
See people follow me on social media and
they're like,
oh,
I see you're in Texas.
You should visit my buddy in Terlingua.
And I did.
And I'll tell you that starting a
minute,
but near,
um,
bisbee this woman,
Dorothy,
I think her name was,
wrote to me and she's like,
dude,
you're in southern Arizona.
You gotta drop in on my buddy,
the rattle snake guy who's been studying
rattle snakes for 50 years by himself.
He's not looking for fame or anything,
but I'll talk to him.
I think he'd,
he'd like you and you guys would enjoy
each other's company.
And so I'm like,
sure,
I'll talk to the rattle snake guy.
Perfect.
So he came out to this camp site and we
hung out for the morning.
The Sky is amazing.
Uh,
John Porter is his name.
He's been studying snakes for 50 years.
He's just totally interested in them,
lives on next to nothing in a trailer in
the desert.
That's his focus has been bit 15 times.
Jesus.
What keeps you fucking with snakes after
byte number 11?
Yeah,
I know.
Full Bite me 10 times.
Shame on me.
This is bullshit.
This job sucks.
Like how many years has he been doing
it?
Fifty years.
50.
He's almost 70.
That's incredible.
And he's in really good shape.
He scrambles around in the hills and and
pull snakes out of holes and.
Wow.
Yeah,
he's a.
he's a really interesting cat and he's
just like,
that's his passion.
That's what he does.
Now,
did he do the slow amount of venom in
his system to try to make himself
immune?
You can't be immune to it because what I
learned from him,
one of the many things I learned from
him is that rattle snake venom is
essentially digestive enzymes.
And what what happens is they bite an
animal.
The animal runs off 20 feet or something
before it collapses.
The enzymes are digesting the animal
from within because they don't have
enough enzymes within their own
digestive tract to digest the whole
thing from outside.
Right?
So when they get the animal inside them,
they're digesting it simultaneously from
outside in and then from inside out
cheap.
So that's why.
What a monster these are,
um,
the snakes that,
that strike a warm blooded animals.
And then the ones that eat cold blooded
animals,
they have the neurotoxins.
That's a different type of.
Here's a terrifying video that I put on
my instagram a couple of years ago.
I think you said rattlesnake one,
you'll never find it.
It's like way back there.
Jamie smiled.
It's a call.
It's a challenge.
Uh,
I retweet it or repost it.
Somebody else's.
Some guys were hunting and a rattle
snake was pulling a rabbit.
And just the way this demon thing just
pulled this poor little fuzzy rabbit.
But I instantly made the
differentiation.
I instantly differentiated which one I
was on team whose team I'm on.
I'm on team,
fluffy,
and furry roadways.
Anything that's very well,
unless,
unless you've got a gun or a bow in your
hands,
well to eat it.
I think the most delicious.
Oh No,
no.
I'm not judging it at all,
but what I'm saying is it's.
But if something else was going after
that snake,
if somebody had killed,
it's like a coyote had killed a snake.
I really wouldn't be bothered by it or
something that bothers me for whatever
weird reason.
I think of a rabbit as being not just a
rodent enlightened form there.
I mean,
I think of it being like fucking Peter
cottontail or something stupid like that
stuff's in your head.
Herbivores.
They're innocent,
right?
They're not out there fucking with other
animals.
So it's kind of like very few
herbivores.
Sometimes they eat the birds,
the birds when they can,
but they're more just opportunistic.
If a bird can't move,
they'll eat a baby bird.
Right?
Yeah.
What is this steak?
First Rabbit?
No,
it's actually dragging a rabbit in the
desert.
It looks like we're in the mountain.
This is the one where the moms saves the
babies.
Oh,
is that what it was?
That happened to me once.
I'll give this to mom.
Rabbit comes over.
Oh,
she sees what's going on.
Wow.
That is crazy.
That is fucking crazy.
No,
that's not the one.
This one was a rattlesnake.
A big ass rattle snake.
And it was dry,
it was just the way it was dragging this
rabbet around was so intense when I was
a kid,
I,
I used to think I was an Indian,
you know,
and I'd wander around the neighborhood
than a loin cloth.
Are you allowed to do that today or
would you get culturally appropriate for
someone to come after you?
I probably,
I mean indecent exposure to because it
wasn't wearing underwear.
Oh you terrible person.
But with going cloth made out of bath
towel,
herbal bath towel.
So it just folded in thirds and I have a
belt come up with a handgun in the front
and the back.
Seriously,
I was totally into it.
But anyway,
I was wondering around the neighborhood
in my Indian thing and uh,
I saw this rabbit and there was a bush
with these hard little fruits on it and
I grabbed on these fruits and I threw it
at the rabbit.
I fucking hit it [inaudible] the rabbit
started flopping and boom,
just laid there.
I was like,
I just killed that fucking with a piece
of fruit with a hard,
like little crab apple or something.
So I walk over and look at the rabbit
and it's just laying there and then I
hear the squeak,
squeak,
squeak under this pine tree.
And I go and there's this nest of little
baby rabbits with their eyes still
closed.
Little tiny ones.
I just fucking killed their mother dude.
I was like,
oh,
what a bummer.
I uh,
so I took the babies home crying.
She really did kill the mother with a
crab.
Apple should have been major league.
He should've been playing for the
dodgers.
Well,
chicken,
I kind of pitch.
So I took the babies home and the next
door neighbor,
my friend's mother was a nurse and I
showed her and she had like a syringe
without the needle and she showed me you
have to mix a can't give them straight
milk because the rabbit milk is thinner
so you have to mix water with it and all
this stuff.
And I was feeding them and,
and then I went back actually a little
while later,
maybe,
I don't know,
the next day or something and the,
the big rabbit was gone.
Which then later in life I thought maybe
it wasn't dead,
maybe it was faking it to try to save
the babies to distract me
more likely coyote.
It,
it made me just a knockout.
You knocked out the rabbit.
That makes sense because if you get hit
in the head with something that you
don't see coming,
it's very likely your branch could just
shut off,
right?
Yeah.
So anyway,
I raised these rabbits.
I'm until,
I don't know,
a few weeks until their eyes opened.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then we'll do them boil them or
from.
Yeah,
no.
Then we had to go visit my,
my uncle in Ohio
and I left the rabbits with this girl
and told her how to take care of them
and all that.
And uh,
the girl apparently forgot about mixing
the water.
And so by the time I got back after a
three day weekend,
a couple of them had died,
but she didn't want to tell me.
And you know,
we were 10,
11 and actually it was all through the
biology teacher.
And then it turned out,
by the time that she told they were all
dead,
they all just died.
They probably would have had a hard go
of it anyway.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Maybe you missed your calling baseball.
Baseball.
So boring.
It's definitely boring.
It's one of those things that you
couldn't.
And people right now are screaming,
fuck you.
Your fans hate me.
Anyway.
Stats.
No,
that's definitely not true.
I see it occasionally attention to those
comments.
They're amusing.
They're only the people that would
comment something shitty.
Yeah.
They're the only ones that are going to
get to you to also.
There's a lot of Kuk Beta stuff,
the because they assume I am in an open
relationship and so therefore there's
all that kind of stuff.
You're that cut thing.
That's interesting.
Anyone who would call someone else a
cook or a Beta male is most likely.
I don't think you could say anyone
because sometimes people just are and
some people say it and they're correct,
but I think been the most part.
But why would you just shut that?
You're not in an argument.
Okay.
You aren't in an argument with them,
you don't know them.
You guys aren't so widely insulting you.
Why are they going after?
It's because of insecurity.
Let's also,
because of this weird way of expressing
each other ourselves on,
on instant,
you know,
on twitter,
facebook and stuff to instant,
that instantaneous ability to just go
after something.
You don't meet them,
you don't establish a friendship with
them.
You don't talk to them is why I'm saying
it's a reflection.
As a psychologist,
I find it really interesting because
it's an,
it's,
you know,
you see these guys every fucking day.
There's another story about an anti gay,
you know,
minister who's been sucking little boys
Dick's everyday or even big black guy,
Dick,
whatever is available dixies into.
But if he's trying to like pray the gay
away.
Yeah,
for sure.
There's some gates going on somewhere.
I think we reveal our deepest secrets in
our loudest accusations.
I think you're right.
You know,
and so this whole,
the trolling and stuff going on online
is interesting because people don't
realize that they're exposing
themselves,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
it's also,
it's a really shitty way of interacting
with humans that some people participate
in almost exclusively,
like there's some people right now in
our culture that they're communicating
with people,
but the people that they're
communicating with,
their,
their only communicating with people
online,
they're only doing it through twitter or
facebook or however they do it,
so like their days are spent interacting
just randomly with people tweeting at
them
and reading tweets or reading,
you know,
reading message board posts or posting
things or reading instagram passages.
All they're doing is interacting with
people online and I just think there's a
lot of kids developing that way because
they're not even.
Even when they're around each other,
they're spending more time communicating
with people through a device than they
are doing it face to face because
they're always distracted and I feel
like this is a very.
It's not indicative of how we evolved
like these,
this method of communication.
So like people say there's way more hate
today than it's ever been before.
I don't think so.
I think it's the same amount of hate.
There's just this new weird form of
expression that doesn't make you take
into consideration the other people's
feelings.
It's like the only time we've ever had
something like that,
like if you killed someone or you beat
someone up and you looked at them and
they looked at you and you knew that you
hated them,
at least that's an honest attack,
but if you're.
If you want something terrible to happen
to someone and you don't even know them,
he just heard him on a podcast.
He was a guest and he annoyed Usi want
terrible things to happen to them like
you're not even.
You don't even know.
It's like traffic,
anger,
you know,
fuck you like that guy in that car.
I know where that comes from.
The right traffic.
Anger comes from a heightened sense of
awareness because you're going so fast
because you're in your car.
Scared.
Yeah,
well,
you're ramped up.
You're looking constantly for anything
to go wrong.
You can't be at zero and just drive.
When you're driving,
you're very aware that you're at the
wheel of a big fucking thing that had
car accidents happen and people die on
them.
Everybody's aware of that.
So you get,
you get ramped up.
Although it's funny.
I wrote a motorcycle everyday for about
seven years and uh,
I felt very calm on the motorcycle.
I think [inaudible] freedom.
It's freedom and vulnerability.
Do you have both the Gemma Harley BMW.
I knew it.
I'm a guy.
I'm not a Harley guy and some European
thing.
Fine,
fine.
Low Center of gravity.
Yeah.
I drove that like a grandpa too.
I was like,
I never got pulled over because in span
I never had a Spanish audience.
Really?
Yeah.
That's amazing because I shouldn't say
that online.
Probably not.
It's too late now.
About um,
yeah.
But,
uh,
the thing in Spanish,
it's funny because if you come from,
you know,
Mexico,
Uganda,
wherever,
and you immigrate to Spain and you get
residency,
you have to turn in your driver's
license and they'll give you a Spanish
license.
Right.
The only country where they won't honor
your license is United States.
Wow.
You got to go to driving school,
that bullshit night school for six
weeks,
take the ridiculous test that's designed
to trick you and it's the translation
into English is incomprehensible it and
then you got to do it again.
It's like 4,000
euros.
It's a giant scam and it's only for us
for America.
And the reason is that all the Spanish
kids were to the US doing
like high school exchange thing and to
get it you have to be 18 to get a
driver's license in Spain.
But in the US 16 obviously.
So they would come here and it's 16.
They'd get a driver's license and then
they'd go back to Spain and say,
hey,
give me the license.
You got to do it.
It's so Spain.
They talked to the American government
like,
Hey,
stop giving Spanish kids licenses.
And the US is like,
fuck you,
we do it the way we do it.
We're number one and let's face.
It was like,
all right,
and then fucking Americans.
And so now it's this giant pain in the
ass if you're an American living in
Spain.
Oh Man.
So what happens if you get caught and
you don't have a license?
So if you're driving around,
you're going to find how much?
A few hundred euros.
That seems like a bargain.
So yeah,
that's what I figured they paid over 10
times in order to.
I was like,
what you do is pretend you're a tourist,
right?
Just in town.
Have your passport,
you know,
don't have a vehicle registered in your
name.
Not that I would ever do any of these
things.
Yeah.
I was reading about a ex pats and about
people who just decide to just like go
and move over to Europe for awhile.
It's totally cup.
Such an adventurous thing to do if you
really think about it as an American
because Americans are for sure locked
into our way of thinking.
Like there's A.
I don't want to speak for the whole
group,
but when you think of the typical
American,
you think of someone who just.
They like things the way they have them
here.
This is the best.
We're number one.
Well those people are getting away from.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
But.
But the point is like if you even have
an a niggling of that and then you
decided to move to Italy for a year,
that will go away.
You will realize like,
oh,
okay,
whatever.
Form One of the.
I think that's one of the reasons why
people cling so hard to those norms I go
because they know.
I think they know that Cambodia is
different.
And if they were living in Cambodia,
they'd be living like Cambodians.
They know that Laos is different.
They know that Vietnam is different.
How could that be?
How could these people in these other
places be just like you just a person,
but they walk around in a rice patty all
day and they pushed an ox and they don't
have cell phones.
Like how did that happen?
Could that have happened to you?
Like if you just got a weird roll the
dice and instead of coming out with a
seven,
you came out with a three.
Could you have been in Laos,
if you.
Unless you know,
I mean,
and uh,
from a Laotians perspective,
he got the 70 and you got the three.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
Guy Take a cubicle,
job is used to working outside and
beautiful weather else is great.
I've been there.
Beautiful,
beautiful country,
gorgeous on video.
I've never seen in real life.
But yeah,
whole thing is just.
I traveled all through my twenties and
thirties was for that insight.
Yeah.
To see it.
You got to see it and you got an
impersonal right?
Yeah.
And you gotta move slowly enough that
you had Joseph Campbell called a d
tribalization to to understand that you
from a tribe,
right?
Everybody thinks everyone else has an
accent,
but I don't,
you know,
there,
there are all these biases that we're
unaware of until you get out and look
back at yourself and where you came
from.
And so I was,
I was based in Spain for 25 years,
so really,
you know,
got into Spanish.
I've lived in Spain longer than I've
lived in any other country.
But you don't speak Spanish.
Charter do for Kelly by skt says I
speak,
I speak badly.
But you speak it.
Yeah,
I understand everything and I sound like
I gave a talk in Argentina once and they
came up after and they said,
I sounded like,
um,
somebody said I sounded like a on Gringo
because I learned Spanish in Catalonia,
so I have this very specific accent in
Spanish,
which I'm totally unaware of.
Of course,
intellectually that makes sense to me,
but my brain is like,
what different Spanish acts,
how the fuck could you tell?
Well,
it's like,
obviously you can take a Spanish person
who learns English in Scotland.
Yeah,
they sound Scottish speaking,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
Or,
or I mean how many number of people that
come from other countries that speak
Spanish or speak English rather,
but they speak it with the accent of
their place in India.
Even Canadians.
It's so subtle about a boat.
A boat.
Yeah.
I went to university and you see here a
few times and they're a little bit too
polite.
You're like,
Hey,
I love fucking with Canadians.
We asked them where they're from or what
part of the states are you from,
and they say,
well,
I'm from Canada.
And like,
yeah,
whatever.
Yeah,
you're James Brown has a song called
living in the USA and he goes through
and you know how he does like he calls
out cities,
Pittsburgh,
PA,
let's live in the North America.
So I guess that's his thing,
right?
Mexico,
there's North America to.
Isn't that crazy?
I shared as North America,
my first,
uh,
apartment in Barcelona.
I shared with this guy named Roy Leo
from Rohelio Gutierrez from Columbia.
Got This fucking serious name and I was
just learning Spanish then.
And uh,
he got,
he got really pissed off at me when I
said I was American because he's like,
we're all Americans,
dude.
Colombia,
South America.
America is the whole Western Hemisphere.
You arrogant fucking need interface.
That's what I had to learn to say in
Spanish.
That means from the United States,
those states one then say suited dense
or united.
Yeah.
So I used to remember that.
I just remember who stato stabbing you
speak any foreign language?
No,
no.
I took A.
I took Italian in college and Spanish in
high school or remembered none of it.
I took three years of German in the
middle school,
high school because I initially signed
up for Spanish,
which would've been the smart move,
but then over the summer I was like
eighth grade I think in over the summer,
uh,
this girl named Judy Gumph,
who I just lusted after Judy
[inaudible],
who she was just telling me about Judy
Judy gown for the 15 year old who was
totally built and gorgeous and smart and
going out with a 23 year old dudes
Camaro and here I am with my zits and
then braces and I'm thinking I got a
shot at good judy Gulf.
So I,
she was taking German and she said,
oh,
but there only eight people in the
class.
I don't know if they're going to do it
because you should have nine.
And I was like,
Judy,
I'm going to call the school and switch
over to chairman.
And I did sat that class for three years
with hair.
Flint and Judy never had a shot at judy
of course.
And then hair.
Flint I,
I could not.
I have no talent for language.
I'm like,
I'm all right in English,
but like when you start talking grammar
and the accusative case and you know,
in German there are three genders in,
in,
you know,
there's deed,
their das,
masculine,
feminine and neutral,
and every noun has a gender and it's
like a fucking nightmare.
So as neutral for objects like Das boot.
Yeah,
right.
Objects.
But also it's weird because like a
mentioned girl is neutral and you would
think girl would have a fucking feminine
gender neutral does,
does mention.
But anyway,
a hair flint was also the soccer coach.
So we sorta had this unspoken agreement
that if I was on the soccer team he
would pass me in German even though I
was lost constantly.
I mean I would have failed out for sure,
but he would give me a c as long as I
was on the soccer team.
Not that I was a soccer star is just
that he needed enough people on the team
that they'd keep paying him or they'd
shut it down.
So my memory of German is basically
humiliation from judy gum because I
never got anywhere,
humiliation and the classes I couldn't
understand the fucking thing and
humiliation on the soccer field because
not only did I suck at soccer but he
would scream at me in German.
So I was in the German class so it was
like God,
it was my tutoring or something.
So like nine dm Copley.
Okay.
My Italian class in high school,
there was this really friendly,
beautiful Puerto Rican girl.
She was beautiful.
Like she was the type of girl that I
would have been way too nervous to ask
out a way too nervous to approach.
I just wouldn't have need.
I would've needed a bunch of green
lights to talk to her.
I'd be super nervous,
but she would approach me and she's
always inviting me to go places with
her,
her and her friends and I'm like,
well what are you guys doing?
Oh,
we're going to camp out,
we're going to do this thing.
And there was this a getaway for the
weekend.
Like one of them I couldn't do.
So I was.
I was fighting back then,
one of them I couldn't do because I had
a fight and one of them I couldn't do
because I think,
I don't remember what the fucking reason
was,
but it was.
It was enough of a reason that I would
say no.
This hot Puerto Rican girl asked me to
go somewhere with her on the weekends.
Beta cook behavior show.
She was so hot.
She was built like a woman.
I mean we're both.
I think I was probably 19 and so she was
probably 19 too.
She was,
she was a phenol mom.
I mean her body was just holy shit.
Super duper pretty and super duper
friendly.
So I'm thinking one day this is going to
happen.
Right?
So I go to the lunch room one day and it
was the day that it was the trump
airplane.
I know I've talked about this before.
The trump airline,
the runway gear didn't come down and
it's skid.
Like remember when trump had an airline?
Do you remember that?
Vaguely,
yeah.
I had a fucking airline side of it and
I'm pretty sure it was him or maybe it
was jet blue.
Now let me think about it.
It might not have been trump or might
have happened either way.
This airplane skid and you know they had
a foam up the runway,
the whole deal and things skin without
the gear and I showed up and was her and
her friends landing gear fails on trump
jet.
No injuries.
Okay.
Nineteen 89.
That is it.
That's exactly when it was happening.
You were in high school in 1980.
That was 89.
That must've been.
I was 21.
No,
that doesn't make sense.
It must have been another one.
See if there was one from earlier
because when I was 21 or two given up on
the idea of college,
they're going to say,
given up on the idea of her.
No.
I was like,
what am I doing?
When I was 21,
I was like,
this is just too ridiculous.
And then I started doing standup was
there was a Mexico City air disaster
believes air international.
Mexico City crash.
No,
it wasn't a crash,
it was the same thing with the landing
gear.
Wouldn't drop down.
Type in airline runway in my memory.
Sucks in Boston.
It wasn't Boston.
Oh,
there you go.
I just can't imagine that I was 89.
I was 21.
Anyway.
So what happened with a woman and yeah,
no,
it's definitely not 89 because I was uh,
I was already doing standup by 89,
so I.
sorry,
I sit down hundreds of thousands of
people that go and just sit down to the
guys here.
What happened today at the airport and
they'll know what happened.
I go,
this jet came in and the landing gear
didn't drop so it had a skid across the
runway.
I go,
but everybody's okay.
And they all go,
praise God.
Oh,
And I went,
oh,
that's the weekend getaway.
The weekend getaway.
It's an indoctrination to a Christian
cult.
They were bananas.
They were in.
They were super proselytizing.
They would go everywhere and sit down
with people that were by themselves.
And if you saw,
if they thought you were lonely or an
outcast,
they would send in the hot one,
she would come and sit next to you and
invite you places and then they'd pull
you into the fold and they were just
recruiting people left and right to
join.
And then like I noticed as the class
would go on,
like later in the semester,
I noticed some of the people from the
class,
we're now in that little tight group and
they'd all hang together.
It was very strange.
It was like I was watching people get,
they got cult it up that was watching it
happen.
But it was all like standard standard,
you know,
Christian stuff,
but extremely involved in your life.
Very rabid.
And you know,
and recruiting,
proselytizing everywhere.
And the fact that this had like,
it was very strange because I was like
cute dummy.
Of course she doesn't like you.
She wants to bring you to Jesus.
You know,
maybe if she was going to fuck you to
Jesus.
I didn't think so.
I didn't have much confidence back then,
believe it or not,
I didn't think it was going to happen,
you know?
Does anyone have confidence at 1920?
Really dumb kids.
Yeah,
that's it.
When I was 19 I was like,
I couldn't,
nothing made any sense.
I might've been 20 when it happened.
Yeah,
if you think you got it figured out in
19 or 20,
you're destined for a life,
you know,
stacking shelves somewhere.
I can't imagine that it was in an 89.
It doesn't make any sense unless my
whole timeline for when I quit college
is off.
I just finished watching.
I'm binge watching this new netflix
documentary about the Roger Nishi.
You know,
the Sunday I was in Oregon.
Wild West.
Wild wild country while.
Well country.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It's really good.
It's how many six episodes I think.
Yeah,
we just binge watched it.
Um,
I have a buddy who was the son Yassa and
for 15 years maybe something like that.
He wasn't in Oregon though.
He was always in India.
But yeah,
that's very interesting.
And the whole sort of appeal of the cult
and the hunger to be part of this
community.
And it was a very interesting
documentary.
Yeah.
Well I don't think it's too hot.
I don't think it'd be very hard at all
to start a cult.
I just don't think it's very difficult.
I think some people would say you
already have.
Well maybe,
but you can do whatever you want.
I mean,
no,
no.
Uh,
no one's asking you for a.
do you have.
Do you have any.
You need to step up your game there.
He goes onto the window.
Like the instead of the Rolls Royces,
you got the porsches,
Porsche,
Porsche Gurus.
I'm realizing I like old cars,
old cars.
You don't even have to drive as good.
They don't have there a different thing.
You ever heard of Mickey Avalon?
Yes.
I had him on my podcast recently.
Really interesting and smart guy.
And He,
in addition to being a rapper and
whatever he does,
he.
Simon rex is a good friend of mine,
a dirt nasty.
And the two of them were on tour
together anyway.
So I was talking with the Mickey and it
turns out Mickey Restores Antique cars.
Wow.
And he's got like 20 of them,
like,
like model t's and shit.
Like that's awesome.
Really interesting
cars.
They're part,
man.
This is what an old car.
They're just,
it's a different thing,
you know,
it's cool to see the process of them
figuring out how to design cars at
faster and faster.
So his car.
Oh God,
that's beautiful.
What is that 61?
Impala.
A Rockford fosgate equipped 61 in Pollo.
I love that sort of art deco lines.
Yeah.
So when he's doing his,
um,
and I think that is a,
what they would call Resto Mod.
You know what they take an old.
This is,
that's the best of both worlds.
They take an old car and they put modern
brakes in modern suspension and they're
just safer and they ride better.
He could even swap out the engine,
right?
Oh yeah.
They all do.
The lot of them do,
I should say,
um,
they use modern fuel injected engine.
You can buy them from almost all the
companies,
Ford sales,
crate engines and people put them in old
mustangs,
so it's amazing.
I love those old Mustang split rear
windows to some of those cars are just.
You look at them and you're like,
God damn like,
what?
What?
How did they do it?
So good then.
And why?
Like you look at those old mustangs are
old corvettes.
Like there are a few years where
corvettes just couldn't have been more
beautiful.
Have you ever seen my 19,
65?
I don't think so too.
It's to correlate his car I've ever seen
in my life.
I have a 1965 silver,
1965 corvette convertible.
Wow.
Stand.
I just sit in front of it.
May have seen it.
Did you and Jay Leno drive around in
that?
Yeah.
Were you in Topanga?
No.
I remember watching that clip and
thinking they're dry.
Oh yeah,
look at that.
No,
we went to the Angeles crest highway.
That car is two years older than me sort
of see,
but sort of as the real thing,
like the outside is everything in the
inside as far as like dashboard and
stuff is.
So you've had the hip replacements and
stuff.
Those are joints.
Yeah.
This car has got any of everything in
that car is modern in terms of like the
breaks and the engines,
engines from a 2007 corvette.
They just do that then that way,
like you're driving around enrolled car,
but it breaks goods at handles good.
It's not a death trap,
but as getting back to the cult thing,
uh,
you know,
I think some of the mechanisms,
the psychological mechanisms that make
that possible apply to what's happening
in podcasting these days.
Yes.
And the beautiful thing about podcasting
is so far no one has taken advantage of
it and started some compound somewhere
and banged everybody's wife didn't file
it or we have this thing on and required
you to give up all your financial money.
Worldly goods and patriotic count
though.
Australian guy that said he was Jesus a
pretty fucking interesting because
there's this whole documentary on it and
he has this woman
and the woman said that he said that she
was married then,
like halfway to the documentary.
You feel that there was another girl in
the past.
He said she was married to a girl,
thinks she's married and he thinks he's
Jesus.
It's fucking hilarious.
Well,
Mary was Jesus's mother,
right?
Uh,
yes.
So,
but they're partying together and
banging because the reincarnated.
So really Mary.
So Jesus was a motherfucker in his,
his own motherfucker.
I don't know.
I love my,
All right.
She's not married.
The mother.
She's Mary Magdalen the uh.
Oh,
the prostitute.
It's fitting in.
Maybe the other.
Mary was the mom is the last gospel.
Is that what he says?
Dan Brown?
Yeah.
The Brown was hanging with the hookers
and very accepting of sex workers.
Yeah.
Why not?
I mean,
God made people horny.
God knew what he was doing,
but God made us monogamous.
Joe.
Oh,
get me started.
It's one of the reasons why I wanted to
have you on.
I have an intervention that Weinstein,
yeah,
you're going to get me married,
you know,
um,
I told you in the email that I felt bad
when your book came up on the show and I
didn't know how to defend it.
I didn't know what to do because I
didn't,
I was in that weird moment where I was
recommending it because I like it
because I think it's a great book.
And he was saying that just debunked.
Well,
I think he picked data right?
Which is always weird.
Well,
the thing is,
any sort of popular non science or
nonfiction book is you have to choose
what data you're going to include,
right?
I mean there's an infinite amount of
data and so of course you form an
argument and then you present data that
supports your argument.
Did you ever consider,
I'm arguing against herself.
Sure.
Yeah.
And in fact the book is,
you know,
the book is written as an argument
against the standard narrative.
So,
you know,
we had to present this.
What is the standard narrative?
Who believes this?
You know,
who thinks that people evolve to as
monogamous.
And so we quote quite heavily from those
people,
um,
but you know,
the thing is I,
and I really appreciated your email and
I,
you know,
we don't need to talk about this at any
length,
but it's not your job to defend the book
and it's not even my job really to
defend the book.
I think once a book is out,
it's out.
The book is there,
but isn't it,
it's not just the book,
it's when someone goes hard on a book,
it's not about you as well is expression
of,
of your
work.
But see,
that's the thing,
I don't accept that association.
And so if somebody wants to critique the
book,
that's totally cool and,
and like,
look,
are there things that we may have
misunderstood?
Of course are the things we left out.
Of course there are,
you know,
mistakes of course you know,
that you're human.
You made it right.
There are hundreds of citations in that
book.
Now,
if somebody says,
as people have like,
you know,
uh,
Chris Ryan,
you know,
deliberately misrepresented the science
or doesn't understand the first thing
about evolution or whatever it is,
I just don't engage because the
emotional cycle,
what we were saying earlier about
comments online,
I think people will react to sex at dawn
very emotionally.
And so if they're reacting emotionally,
there's no point in me engaging with
them because they're expressing some
something that's going on in their lives
that I don't know anything about and I
don't,
they're suffering in some way.
I'm not talking about Weinstein or
anybody specifically,
but there's an emotional reason to have
that kind of reaction.
Whereas if somebody says,
look on page 72,
you said that a Benobos are the only ape
that does this and the actually gibbons
do it as well.
Okay.
We can talk about that,
you know,
that's,
that's factual.
So when people say,
oh,
it's cherry picked,
well,
which cherries?
What are you talking about?
Specific thing and what's wrong with it?
Instead of saying it's cherry picking is
vast.
General critic critique of the book.
And if it gets about me,
like,
oh,
that's because he wants to get laid,
or one of the arguments was that it
would be a good book to write.
I think.
I don't remember if he said or if his
wife said it,
it'd be a good book.
And I really loved those two.
They're great.
They're cool.
I just think,
um,
when it comes to monogamy and sexuality,
people have a notion in their head and
that notion almost always aligns with
how they're living their life or how
they wish they were living their lives.
Yeah.
Maybe.
And again,
we're not talking about specific people
or I've never met them.
I know they're a great couple.
They're wonderful people.
But I mean there's,
there's something about the subject of
your book.
I think I told you this before,
without naming any names.
My friend brought your book home and his
wife threw it away.
Yeah.
You and I talked about that on the very
first podcast actually.
Yeah.
I've run into this a lot,
right?
You can imagine cocktail parties with
me.
It can get awkward very quickly for
sure.
You know,
cause people ask,
oh wait,
you're the guy who.
Yeah,
you know,
and then often you'll see some people
are very eager to hear about it and talk
about it.
Other people are just steams coming out
of their ears.
I,
I think,
you know,
a lot of people are in relationships
that they're trying to make fit into
what they believe is the right way to
have a relationship and often it just
doesn't.
It doesn't work.
And so there's a lot of shame and regret
and resentment and all kinds of negative
energy around that.
And
so any discussion where you're saying,
well maybe that's not actually the way
it's meant to work for some people,
that's an incredibly liberating message
for other people.
It's extremely threatening.
Right.
And I understand that.
And,
and you know,
so I've become very emotionally sort of
separate from the book.
It's out there,
it stands or not based on its merits.
I don't.
When people get all riled up,
I've learned to just be like,
yeah,
you know what?
That's fine.
That's between you and the book.
That's a very healthy approach.
Good for you.
It's just,
to me,
it seems like people that get most upset
about it don't get most upset about it.
For rational reason.
They get upset about it because it
challenges the way they live their life.
Well,
that's.
I mean that's what I was saying about
the gay preachers and stuff.
It's like if you're getting that upset,
that's about you,
man.
It's not.
I mean,
if he disagreed with it,
then disagree with it.
That's fine.
Is out gay preachers,
people who love Jesus and are also gay.
You can't do that.
You can't figure that out.
How can this guy can start a whole
fucking call it in Australia and tell
people about Jesus and his girlfriend's
Mary and you guys can't get together and
form yourself a nice gay church.
I mean,
do they have them that I don't know.
The Vatican Dude,
hey,
have you heard all this stuff going on
in Italy?
They've got all their sex parties or
their own country.
Do you know when I was there when you
just walk around the Vatican and just
see the vast amount of pilfered riches
that are all just sucked out by an
ideology.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
That church,
that whatever the fuck you want to call
it a religion,
they just acquired an ungodly amount of
wealth.
Literally ungodly,
ungodly.
Yeah.
It's fucking stunning.
Jesus is all about living in poverty and
hanging out with sex workers and these
guys are like just lavish wealth and
it's crazy because if Jesus came back,
the first thing he'd say,
he's like,
what the fuck have you guys done?
Yeah.
Like what have you done?
Look at these gigantic places that you
built and I told you guys,
you don't even have to be anywhere for
this.
You don't.
You don't need to have some ornate
temple with stain glass windows.
And it took craftsman like St Peter's
Basilica.
Like,
is it a shock that that is probably one
of the most stunning things that I've
ever seen in my life.
Like one of the most beautiful works of
art,
yet was created for this religion that
most likely the people that were living
in that day were probably like
worshiping these people that were
running this thing because if they were
dating themselves and they needed them
to have the biggest,
craziest building that impressed the
rubes right when they come into the
country side and they walk into a
cathedral like,
holy fuck,
the impact that it has on us.
You can't understate it still.
Yeah.
And there,
there are churches in.
I would go into
it and I'm,
I'm a pagan,
but just go in there and just feel the
space.
Yeah,
just feel it.
The distance you just,
you,
your body knows how big it is or can
you.
It's like when you walk into an airplane
hangar,
you know,
uh,
it's,
it's not something you really can't
overemphasize how crazy it is.
Like these people built this without
power tools.
I mean,
I don't know what kind of fucking
ladders they used,
but whatever they did it.
Look at that.
Fuck man.
I mean,
it's just crazy.
You walk around that place,
you can't believe how ornate it is,
but at the same time this was happening.
People were starving,
you know,
guaranteed.
Like how old is that?
Fifteen hundred 15.
Oh,
six.
How well do you think everybody was
doing financially in 15?
Oh,
six.
I bet.
Pretty fucking shitty.
I bet everybody that lived around that
place suffered and these motherfuckers
were building these crazy places.
They have an obelisk in this whole place
where you're these images right here.
Where's Sean from?
Egypt?
This massive stone obelisk from Egypt
and I was like,
okay,
how the fuck did they get that there?
Yeah.
It shows you how cheap labor was.
Oh,
do.
Yeah.
You could hire people for a lifetime,
for a pittance,
you know?
Yeah.
Really skilled artisans down.
They couldn't go anywhere,
man.
What they did in that place,
I mean the Vatican is just a.
it's a stunning place,
like way more so than I thought it was
going to.
Have you been to Spain?
No,
I have not looked at that.
Oh my God,
look at that.
That's what is that Jamie?
What are we looking at?
Is that the roof?
Just St Peter's Basilica.
Look at the fucking carving and
everything and I'm telling you these.
It's one of those things like you were
talking about how you have to see
another culture in per person owner to
really appreciate it.
I think that's the same with this thing.
St Peter's basilica is one of those ones
when you're there,
like,
look how little those people are walking
around down there.
See the top of their heads.
That's it.
Fucking places.
Giant,
beautiful light coming through.
They're unbelievable.
It's,
it's,
it's one of those game changers when you
leave,
they're like,
to me it was way more impressive than
the calcium.
Calcium is very impressive,
but it wasn't as impressive.
What's not intact,
but it's not even that.
It's just like what it is,
what it is,
just craziness.
He's fucking impressive thing was the
elevator complex.
The dates set up the animals up from the
floor like that is fucking nuts,
man.
Do you ever think about the coliseum
when you're doing UFC commentary and
it's kind of like this modern a little
bit,
right?
Yeah.
It's definitely a big violent
distraction from everyday life that
people really look forward to and enjoy,
you know,
for like entertainment value.
I mean it says it's primal as you can
get without anybody really dying,
you know?
I mean that's most of the time.
Most of the time,
I mean no one has in the UFC ever,
but it's because they have the most
rules and because they have the best
medical staff and the best referees and
all that stuff,
but it's also just luck because like
people can die sparring.
It happens.
What
if you're,
if you're in a choke hold and you don't
tap out,
you just go unconscious and then when
they and then you'll be all right.
Yeah,
you'd be fine and you can feel when
someone goes unconscious,
the muscles relax.
They just slump,
slumping the referee.
Sometimes the referee like pickup and
arm,
the old progressing move like they would
check to see if the guy was still awake.
I didn't pick the arm and the crowd
would go back.
Yeah,
he's about to make us come back.
But they do do that sometimes.
Referee.
I've seen referees pick a guy's arm up,
see if the guy responds,
or girl,
you have two girls get choked out bunch.
Um,
but you know,
people are tough.
They don't want to tap and then we'll
wind up going to sleep.
Holly Holm,
when she fought me,
she tate,
Misha Tate,
choked or unconscious and before holly
went out she was throwing punches in the
air and she went unconscious.
It's crazy.
It was crazy.
It was,
it was prime.
Most drownings like watching someone
drown,
you know.
Um,
so it's just,
you know,
you have a preference for how you die.
Drowning drownings.
My one of my least favorite seems like
it would suck.
Yeah.
I don't want to do that.
I have a buddy,
he's a big wave surfer and a like 40
foot waves.
Shout out to kyle and he did a breath
holding course and he can hold his
breath for five minutes.
Jesus,
because he goes,
you know,
if you get caught in one of those waves,
you're like down in the deep for a long
time.
Yeah.
Some really interesting.
He was telling me some really
interesting things like when a human
being puts its face in the water,
all sorts of physiological changes start
happening.
Your metabolism immediately slows way
down your oxygen consumption cuts way
back just automatically.
We've got a lot of seemingly
evolutionary adaptations to living in
the water.
Yeah.
Have you ever heard
that aquatic ape theory?
Does that make any sense?
Does it fit citi?
Someone should have already known that
already.
It makes.
Here's what it does in my opinion.
We should explain it.
Yeah.
So the idea is I first read about it in
a book by Buckminster Fuller,
actually.
Great.
You know about him?
Yes.
Genius.
Uh,
the idea is that there,
according to the people who support this
theory,
there was a period in human evolution
where our ancestors lived in title
areas,
so they spend most of their time in the
water that was about body temperature.
So it was comfortable and it was shallow
enough that they weren't worried about
sharks coming in and deep enough that
leopards and other predators from the
land couldn't get at them.
So it was safe in that respect.
Also,
you have a great sight lines so you can
see if something's coming from a long
way off and there's lots of there lots
of mollusks
and fish and you can net and so it sort
of made sense that they would be there.
And so we have these physiological
adaptations for aquatic living.
Like for example,
human infants are the only ape.
Certainly,
I don't know,
primary,
probably the only primates that know to
hold their water or hold their breath
underwater.
Mm.
So like that.
Great.
A nirvana album.
Cover the baby.
So you take a baby and dropped it in
water and it holds its breath and
breathe and die.
Yeah.
Whoops.
Gemstone can't even swim.
So,
uh,
there's that,
there's the fact that babies are really
fat.
So they flood.
You can't teach chimps to swim?
No.
And also chimps don't have enough body
fat to be buoyant.
Right?
They're super core.
Did steal their bodies.
I didn't know they could never teach
them to swim.
That makes sense to,
but they're so smart.
I guess they just can't do it.
Huh?
I don't know.
But yes,
if you see lots of contemporary zoos,
they have the chimps surrounded by a
moat right across the moat.
Wow.
What a bummer.
They'll wait in water.
I've seen chimps waiting,
but you know,
maybe then there's also the connection
between eating fish and fish oil and
brain health.
Right.
And it was a very strong correlation
between fish oil and brainhealth.
Yeah.
So it could be related to fatty acid
development and also you would have to
be clever to try to dive into the water
to go after those things.
The smarter ones would probably survive,
right?
Even the nostrils like a nostrils come
straight out of the face.
And the idea of our nostrils facing down
is related to the aquatic wow.
A explanation.
The oil glands that we have on our heads
and faces and shoulders that,
you know,
cause acne and stuff and teenagers,
uh,
that's for protection from the sun
apparently.
So there are lots of adaptations that
seem to fit into this interpretation,
but you know,
lots of sort of mainstream evolutionary
theorists would say,
well wait a minute,
you know,
there are other adaptations we don't
have and that we would have if that had
been the case.
So it's,
it's controversial at best.
Part of it was also the theory that the
human brain,
in order for us to be born vaginally,
the brain could only be so big before
the kid was born.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I mean that's the explanation for why
humans are born helpless.
No,
but what I'm saying is that we really
can't.
The brain can't get any bigger,
right.
Vaginal canal,
unless our dicks get bigger and the is
get bigger as well.
I still hold bit about that,
about Dick Pills,
but if they're really word Dick Pills,
no one's stopping at one.
Like what's the dosage?
Okay,
how much gives me a stroke?
I'm going to take one less than that.
All the fucking dice or it.
And the idea would that be every dude's
Dick would just
become a super dick.
And every woman will be,
you know,
she.
It was a joke about flying squirrel,
pussy people.
They would just jump dudes with big
dicks and shopping carts.
We chase these girls to the edge of
cliffs.
The women would leap off with their
vaginas.
Bonnie would have to more to have to
change for the big Dick Pills,
but it doesn't.
It does seem like if pew ones are going
to get smarter,
if the head is going to have to get
larger,
does that make any sense or is that just
a crude way of looking at the brain?
Is it possible that people can get
smart?
Like if we evolved,
have you.
If we evolved from lower hominids,
it's generally assumed that those lower
hominids had little brains or brains
than us right up until like Australia
pit tickets or something like that.
What really seems to matter though is
the ratio of brain size to body size,
right?
There are plenty of animals that have
bigger brains than us that aren't
obviously aren't smarter than us.
Like elephant elephants,
blue whales,
blue whale brains.
Probably the size of this room.
Do we know if elephants are fucking
super smart because isn't the thing
about intelligence is not just like
there's communication between elephants
for sure,
and we know that they recognize each
other after long periods of time,
like 20 years apart,
they get together and they see each
other and recognize each other
instantly.
Sure.
So there's a,
there's an intelligence that,
but what we judge it,
intelligence oftentimes depends on
whether or not it can communicate with
you whether or not it changes its
environment builds a structure.
I mean,
that's,
to me,
this is one of the deepest questions in
life.
Do you see the elephant that painted a
picture of it?
Sure.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
In Thailand I think.
Yeah.
It's pull.
Pull that up.
That is one of those things where you
go,
okay,
wait a minute,
a dog can't do that.
I thought you said this thing was a
smart as a dog because that's 100 times
they're like grey parrots that have 300
word vocabulary or ceiling.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't,
don't quote me on that number,
but Jamie can look that up there as they
can speak a whole sentence and they can.
And there's a guy,
I remember seeing this recently,
there's a guy who has a border Collie
who obviously can't talk but understands
well over 100 words and so what he'll do
is he'll put all these different toys
behind a wall and he'll say,
go get me the,
the yellow bunny.
And there's like a yellow bunny or red
bunny in a green bunny in addition to
the hundreds of other shit.
And the dog will go find the yellow
bunny and bring it back.
Whoa.
You know,
go get me the,
the,
you know,
the green turtle and you'll go get it.
So the dog knows those words.
Right?
And also the dogs.
He's in color.
I Guess Predator,
I guess you're seeing color think.
So here's the elephant painting itself.
It is fucking crazy because it really
looks like itself and this guy helps it
and gets the brush and puts it in his
hand.
But the elephant is essentially doing
all of this with its trunk.
And just replicating itself and it's
proportional to its.
It's really good.
That's better than if the dude was
holding his Tusk,
training them to do that.
I think.
Well I'm sure their training or is he
just pulling goes where they wanted to
see,
look at the trunk.
Like he's definitely holding,
but look at the trunk and look at how
much motion is in that thing.
How could he possibly be controlling
that?
He's definitely lifting it up and down
and helping them now.
But what it is,
is they're working together like the
elephant knows to stay in these lines.
It's doing it with him.
You're not buying it in a mirror or
anything.
The hand on the Tusk is.
There's another one.
There are other ones,
but let me see the other articles that
say that they're being trained to do it
and it's cruel or something.
Yeah.
Okay.
This one right here,
this thing doesn't have anybody's hands
on it.
I think this is the one that I had seen
before.
Let's see if there's any cases.
The question of intelligence is so much
more complicated than we generally
credited with,
uh,
not only among animals but also among
humans.
There's this big controversy,
the perennial controversy.
That's the problem right now.
We're constantly,
we're looking at another video and this
is the one that I had seen his.
Nobody's,
nobody's touching.
Nobody's controlling him here.
Well,
he doesn't have any tusks it looks like.
Does he know?
So that looked like the guy was just
giving them the brush and he was doing
it.
Why don't they pull back though?
So you could see if that's true.
See,
this is the one that I had seen before.
He hadn't seen the other one.
This one.
I would imagine that,
yeah,
this is an assistant.
I would imagine that if you did get a
guy like this that teaches is elephant
how to,
how to paint a fucking picture that
you're going to.
It's going to become a tourist
attraction.
People are going to say,
come and watch the elephant that paints
the picture.
You as seen on Youtube.
And then next thing you know you've got
a tourist business.
Well,
and if he always does the same picture
to write,
draws himself over and over again,
but it's right here.
It looks to me at least like the
elephants doing that.
You couldn't even talk a four year old
and doing that.
So you know what I'm saying?
Like four years here at elephant,
you have to ask him what the fuck it is
like,
what is that like?
That's an elephant.
You're like,
whoa.
That elephants crazy.
What does it do you think it knows it's
drawing an elephant or it's.
That's a good question,
Mike.
The Toronto tree,
he probably doesn't know is drawing an
elephant.
If I had to guess I would get out of
guests that it probably doesn't
understand the two d space like that
because if it did,
it would start creating art.
They start expressing themselves to each
other.
They start drawing directions like go
this way.
If you start seeing animals do that,
that is so far beyond using tools.
That's what bees do.
These do it with smells,
right?
Well,
they do it with a dance.
Yeah,
they.
They give instructions on where the
flowers are.
So this question of intelligence is
really interesting and I think very
important because you know,
we talk about intelligence as if know
what it is,
but we don't,
it expresses itself in so many itself in
so many different ways.
There's so many manifestation.
So this big controversy that's happening
now among,
in between,
I don't know if you're aware of this was
Sam Harris and I'm as recline and Andrew
Sullivan and people are trying to.
Charles Murray,
right,
exactly.
That whole thing about people that don't
know what that Charles Murray wrote this
book called the Bell Curve,
I don't know,
20 years ago or something,
25 even where he argued that,
uh,
there are racial differences in
intelligence,
a ICU specifically with Asians being the
highest and then whites and then blacks
and that,
that's just the way it is.
And social adjustments aren't going to
change that because it's largely
genetic.
And as I understand that was the
argument.
I haven't noticed saying largely
genetic,
but I think they're saying that genetics
play a factor and environment plays a
factor.
I think some people are not willing to
look at genetics if it shows an
unfavorable trait in minorities.
They don't want to look at it.
They,
yeah,
they did not true,
but I think it's also true that part of
the argument is that social programs are
a waste of money because they're not
going to affect it because it's genetic.
That's crazy.
I that I'm pretty sure that the argument
that's just straight racist to me.
Well,
I think that's what people are the idea
like save your money to save your money.
No.
Do a better job.
Like you don't even know if it works
because what have you done?
Like what?
Well go to an inner city school and
pretend you're a 10 year old kid trying
to get by in this life and you're
literally seeing gang members and
craziness and people flashing cash and
people dropping out because they're
pregnant when their 13th and you're
trying to tell me there's not.
There's not some sort of a massive
environmental factor.
If you are a white kid going to a school
like that.
I only went to a bad school for one year
of my life.
I'm not,
I'm no Oji,
but I really did go to one bad school,
Mary curly,
a Middle School in Jamaica Plain and the
Jamaica Plain,
Massachusetts.
It's now it's become gentrified,
sort of.
It's kind of like East la or I'm a
silver,
silver lake area,
you know,
a lot of hipsters have moved in and nice
places,
but when I lived there it was not good.
It was very poor people in the fucking
middle school was scary.
It was scary.
Seventeen year old kids and my seventh
grade class,
no one it'd be,
it was just a weird play.
Maybe.
I guess it was eighth grade,
but the point was these kids were.
They were never going to graduate.
They knew it and they were trying to go
back to seventh grade again or eighth
grade,
whatever the fuck it was,
and the teacher would have them in the
class for a couple of days and then they
would leave and everywhere you walked
you were scared everywhere you walk.
Like some weird shit was happening with
people.
People yelling at people.
There was always tension
and there was always like bigger kids
around that were robbing other kids,
like fuck.
Like I got through that year going,
Holy Shit,
and when I got out of there,
my parents moved,
moved to a really nice part of town,
Newton.
But if you're a kid growing up in that
environment,
good fucking luck learning anything
good.
Fucking probably it's,
it's pretty bad at home too.
Yeah.
And what I experienced in Jamaica plain
was nothing compared to Dorchester and
Roxbury.
Those are the bad areas.
They were way worse.
And we know that anxiety,
stress,
um,
stops brain development.
Yes.
Retards.
It also makes people much more inclined
to violence when you're,
when you grow up in the,
even in the womb,
if your mother's around horrible
situations and people screaming and
fighting and that cortisol and
adrenaline and all those,
all those hormones are flowing through
that baby.
Pairing that baby for a violent world.
Well,
I'm sure you know about the epigenetics
that show that,
that can pass several generations.
Your grandfather was in a famine.
You're more likely to be obese and that
crazy.
It's not.
Yeah.
You also live longer though,
not weird like the people that were,
um,
that were in famine people,
their kids lived longer for some strange
reason.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Like your body is preparing you and be
extra durable like we were talking about
before the podcast started.
And fasting is the only intervention
that's ever been shown to extend
lifespan.
Mm.
Nut nuts.
Yeah.
I do it because it makes me.
I'm just function better.
I do it every 16 hours.
I,
I eat,
so uh,
I'll eat and then I don't eat for 16
hours so I'll eat for eight hours a day.
That's it.
When that's over,
that's over 9:00
AM to 5:00
PM or whatever it is.
I just figured out what the time is and
then add 16 to it cheating.
I add 14 but I never had less than 14.
I see.
Yeah.
I was talking to a guy recently about
this.
I'm Brian Fries and you're in Austin.
Really,
really smart guy.
And we were talking about this and he's
like,
I only eat when the sun's up.
It's easy to keep track of.
That's good.
And what if you want to go to a nice
dinner?
Don't eat cow,
go earlier.
I know you got to have cheat days.
When he said it,
I was like,
dude,
you know,
I spend most of my life in Spain were
dinnertime is 10:00
PM.
Like,
that's not gonna work for me.
If I go to a restaurant,
I'll allow myself to have a little bit
of bread,
allow myself to have dessert,
occasionally,
allow myself to eat some shitty things,
maybe a little pasta.
Feel like fuck it.
You have to be.
I think you have to both be disciplined.
And also I enjoy the art form of
cooking.
I enjoy that people make these delicious
dishes.
Follow your elk and a Jalapeno instagram
feed there.
Joe Looks Great.
Do you cook at all?
I love cooking.
Yeah.
I have meat for you then.
Oh,
I have sausages Joe Rogan has made.
For me.
It was one of the early Beta thing
again.
So tell you a great.
We're talking
about
the van.
You know that my favorite thing in life
is travel.
And the reason I love travel is that you
can wake up and have no idea what your
life's going to be like by the time you
go to bed.
Right,
right.
So we're driving the van through along
the Rio Grande de and we want to go to a
big bend national park,
which is beautiful.
It's,
you know,
where that is.
It's like that part of Texas and sort of
dips down and then,
you know,
and there's like a big Ben don't
literally a big Ben that's the river.
Um,
so it's way down South Texas.
That's a weird spot.
It's cool.
It's,
it's,
it's interesting in south Texas.
Strange.
Yeah.
She'd have a passport to go there.
I in the rivers like as wide as this
room.
I mean,
it's nothing,
you know,
you could just walk across over to
Mexico.
Wow.
Um,
but anyway,
so,
so we get into,
uh,
the western entrance of big band and
it's like 4:00
PM and the guy says,
yeah,
all the campgrounds are full.
And it was like,
ah,
Shit.
Okay,
can I get a back country permanently?
No,
you can't,
you gotta.
Okay.
So he says,
just go back to a little town right
there,
spend the night there and then come in
the morning and I'll hook you up.
Okay,
great.
So we'll go back to this town.
It's called Terlingua little town.
We just drove through it on the way in,
nothing there,
you know,
some houses,
whatever.
And um,
and we find this restaurant and it's
like,
okay,
we're just going to crash behind a
dumpster in the van and,
you know,
whatever.
And uh,
spend the night there.
So we're sitting there and I remembered
somebody had sent me an instagram direct
message like about Terlingua.
So I'd go back and I find it and the
guy's like,
hey,
if you get to Terlingua,
Texas,
you should look up my buddy tony.
He's really cool.
So here's his,
his handle site.
You can't tell people that you're
willing to do this because now they're
going to be sending you direct messages.
Oh,
they do it all the time and see bits.
You're paranoid it was going to be a
dude with a ball gag in his hand and
you've got to go what?
And then you get to feel that wet cloth
filled with chloroform.
See,
you're in a different world.
Joe.
I'm,
I'm in a world of micro podcasting where
everybody who reaches out to me,
he likes me,
he reaches out to you,
I'm sure,
and they're not crazy.
They're just want to tie you up a
little.
Hey,
what's wrong with that?
I remember showing you what time,
long time ago I was here doing a podcast
in my phone and a message came in and I
looked and it was this really hot woman
in Australia who liked to send me naked
pictures of herself and I showed it to
you and you're like,
that's a trap.
It's a trap trap.
Trap,
trap.
Looks like right there.
They are different over there.
They're there.
They're far away.
They are interesting people.
Anyway,
that's a place I would live.
I like Australia.
It would live there.
Trillion people.
They're funny,
as funny as fuck,
but they get American comedy straight
away.
Like there's no.
There's no problem with doing shows over
that.
Humor is an interesting thing.
Cultural Humor.
Anyway,
let me finish this story.
So I texted this dude,
I'm like,
Hey,
I'm interlink way,
you don't know me,
but some friend of yours,
whatever.
He texts us back if you were in this
restaurant,
come have a beer.
So we go to this restaurant,
there's this table,
maybe a dozen people center the table,
Hey,
come buy a,
have a beer.
A really nice people.
Uh,
after about 15 minutes I say to
somebody,
are you guys tripping?
He's like,
yeah,
we,
we ate some mushrooms.
Some of them did,
some of them did anyway,
but super relaxed and uh,
somebody makes some joke about like,
their,
their beer glass was dirty or something
and someone else's like,
yeah,
just lick it.
It's good for your microbiome.
And I'm like,
Oh,
you guys know about microbiome?
Like,
yeah,
yeah.
I said,
I read this article a couple of years
ago.
This dude,
you probably read this article yourself.
This dude was in Africa with the Hadza
people,
the hunter gatherers,
and he took some Hadza shit and he mixed
it up and blasted it up his ass to see
if he could get a hunter gatherer is
microbiome because it's a much more
complex microbiome.
Right.
I say this to this dude thinking he's
gonna have a reaction like you just had,
and he says,
oh yeah,
that's him.
He points to the end of the table.
I said,
what have you guys have?
No Air's coming.
The guys look at me,
smile and I said that you,
that's you.
He's like,
yeah.
He asked me.
You blasted fucking 100 gala.
Yeah,
yeah.
I do this thing in Africa.
This guy is a world famous scientists,
microbiome expert,
spends half his life in Africa with this
hunter gatherer group and the other half
in this tiny little town in Texas and
there he is,
and so we stayed there for days.
Became great friends with this guy.
I did a podcast with him.
Fantastic.
Jeff Leach.
I'm going to tangentially speaking the
podcast available on Itunes,
stitcher,
and everywhere else available.
We're fine.
Podcasts are found.
Wow,
I'm going to listen to that one.
That sounds amazing.
What a coincidence was the trip and that
was totally fell out of the sky.
We went to visit Peter Gorman,
you know him.
He was editor of High Times magazine in
the seventies.
First person to write about Iowasca in
the western press.
Not Scientifically,
but popular press.
Oh Wow.
Explore the Amazon for years.
Was all over down there.
First person to write about Sapo,
you know the,
the burn.
Yeah.
Really interesting dude.
He's in Texas too.
Wow.
We drove up to see him.
So it's Kinda like just cruising around
in the van,
like hanging out with cool people.
I heard that frog poison stuff is
horrible that the trip.
Yeah,
I mean I guess it was Aubrey wasn't an
artery that was on the podcast talking
about doing the tree frog poison.
Pretty sure it was him.
He's done everything.
He's like Mikey from that commercial,
but for life he hates everything.
He's in there.
That's all
he loves.
Everything takes everything.
But he,
um,
he was saying it was just a terrible
ordeal,
but there was,
um,
there was also an article that I read
about certain countries where they
didn't have an endogenous psychedelic or
didn't have a local psychedelic,
so these people would take ordeal
poisons,
so they would take poisons that would
get them like literally to the brink of
death and then they would come out of it
like a near death experience and that
this near death experience provided some
sort of a shamanistic,
you know,
um,
uh,
some sort of a breakthrough experience
where you could move on to the next
level.
Like you had experienced something that
was like,
like we were talking about before the
podcast,
like when you lived in Portland and then
coming here in la when it's sunny out,
you're like,
ah,
Simon,
you just feel it like that.
It's similar,
a similar theory about a Africa that
there aren't a lot of endogenous
psychedelic plants.
They're Boga is one of the only ones and
that's incredibly strong and not
available all over the continent.
And so they develop complex rhythms to
provoke a altered state.
Hmm.
That makes sense and that's why African
rhythms are so complex and native
American rhythms are very simple.
That's because they were hot as fuck,
fuck already.
And just boom,
boom,
boom.
As you know.
Have you heard,
have you ever heard any of the Eco rose
that ob replays when he has his little?
No,
they.
He's got these arrows that he got from
these South American Shamans and I
listened to him sometimes when I write
because I like listening to things that
I don't know the language when I write
like I like a guy,
like some music from Armenia,
some Lebanese music I like.
It's cool listening to things where I
have no idea what they're saying so I
don't get wrapped up in what I feel
their emotions,
but I don't get wrapped up in whatever
they're talking about so I can write
about whatever fucking table tops.
So a lot of good music out there.
And Brazilian.
The African?
Yeah.
I.
Most of the music I listened to,
I don't understand the words because I
really fixate on the words if I do.
The ECO rows are crazy because they,
they make the psychedelic trip dance to
them,
like dmt dmt with the negroes.
You realize like the [inaudible].
It's like a technology that was invented
to work with DMT,
right?
Like this is like,
give me some volume on this shit.
This is what they sound like
now by itself.
You listen to this right now and you go,
oh,
this is just like some weird slow music,
but when you're in the dimension of
dimethyltryptamine and the world has
become infinite fractals that are moving
and changing and morphing.
When you hear this song,
the hallucinations or whatever they are
that you're experiencing the
visualizations,
they danced to the song 100 percent in
sync,
so all this.
It's comforting.
Yeah.
That's another thing that keeps people
from having bad trips sometimes because
they can cling to the music and the
structure in the music.
Whereas their own paranoia and fear and
inability to let go gets hit with that
psychedelic Jews and just experienced
that new and some people freak out,
but this music might be able to bring
them down.
It sounds like what a fetus might hear
in the womb
got that heartbeat to.
Yeah,
right.
Imagine what fetus here.
See,
I like listening to this kind of shit
when I write because I don't have no
idea what they're saying and so I can
just keep it on the background and also
makes me feel like just knowing,
just knowing that that's out there,
knowing that the DMT world is out there,
it makes me just a little bit nervous.
It makes you write better when you're
writing jokes or others,
everything,
whatever.
Either you ever written a book or essay
or stuff.
I've written essays to write a lot in
some of your essays.
One,
are we talking about it?
Yeah.
You run a beautiful one couple of years
ago about that that I really,
I don't know if I've ever told you how
much I appreciated that actually.
It was about,
um,
how the quest for optimal fitness
shouldn't be taken as in mortality.
That we're all going to die.
And do you got to sort of deal with
that?
Do you remember what I'm talking about?
I think I wrote your body's a
sandcastle.
That's what it is.
Sand castles are beautiful,
but one of the beautiful things about
this,
we know how temporary they are when you
see a sand castle,
it's not just like,
oh,
this guy made an amazing sculpture,
so I go,
no,
this person made something that they
know is not going to last,
and they put a massive amount of work
into it,
but part of the beauty of it is that a
soft collar?
Yeah.
I really,
I enjoy that.
I think that was for a magazine.
Yeah.
I forget what magazine.
So you have a book in mind.
I started writing a book and then I had
to deal with the publishing company,
like wanting.
They wanted very specific kinds of
writing.
Oh,
that's.
Yeah.
It's for maximum.
That's what it was.
Um,
they wanted very specific,
like they want a jokey jokes.
They,
they even offered to just pay me to
transcribe my act.
And I was like,
I don't want to do that.
And they go,
but these people did it.
Some famous comedians did it.
I said,
that's fine.
I just not what I want to do.
I like writing,
but I like writing shit that I feel like
writing,
like I don't,
I don't want to have some.
So when we went into it they like,
we love your blogs,
we think you're really funny.
Uh,
this will be good for you had the
podcast.
Yes.
Yeah,
so I gave him all their money back.
I just,
I don't want to do this.
Yeah,
just at this point on free,
free range to do whatever you want it.
I just think that anytime you willingly
take on some new project
managers and others,
they might like their,
their opinion might very well be valid,
but I'm not looking for it.
I want whatever I write to be out of my
head and whether it's good or bad,
dependent upon how much focus and
attention I put into it,
you know,
I,
I'm pretty self critical so if I think
it's Clunky,
I'll try to Redo it,
but I'm not interested in like
artistically or creatively going down a
direction where somebody else is picking
the subject matter or somebody else's
suggesting like,
I'm not.
That's fine.
There's no reason for you to do that.
I mean,
you've got the massive platform and well
established voice.
You don't.
I think honestly,
I think publishing is at the napster
stage right now.
I think it's.
It's sort of collapsing.
I'm at,
I'm finishing this book I've been
working on for a few years now and I
don't know that I'll ever published
another book with major publishers will.
You've had great success with
podcast as well,
but the beautiful thing about your
podcast is it allows you to put out an
idea almost instantaneously.
I mean you get together with this
rattlesnake guy,
you guys have a couple of our
conversation.
You upload that shit and that's it.
It's wonderful and it brings these
really interesting people into my life
and my circle of friends now is largely
composed of either guests or listeners
of the podcast.
You know,
it's.
Yeah,
it's wonderful.
I just put out a book recently that's a
sort of compilations of podcasts,
so it's not the whole conversation
obviously,
but it's excerpts and the whole thing
was crowd sourced.
So people who listen to the podcast pick
the episodes they picked,
what part of the episodes that they
thought was most interesting.
They transcribed it.
This Guy Adam mcdade did all the art,
the publisher misfit press or people
that I know through the podcasts.
They reached out to me and we had some
beers and it was not intending to do
anything together.
Just like,
hey dude,
we're in town and we'd like your show.
Can we get a beer and really liked these
guys and ended up having the CEO on the
podcast aj and um,
yeah.
So we just put out the book and it's,
it sort of fulfills my fantasy of being
a writer without having to write,
you know,
if I could,
I do what you're in it,
you,
you remember you signed a release for
her.
I remember remember that Joe,
you and Duncan and Duncan and my mother
blurbed it.
It's.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah.
You don't even know you blurbed it.
We just lifted something you said on a,
on a podcast about you.
He said,
perfect.
Was.
He said,
whatever it is,
I sign off on it now.
You said Chris is the,
is the best Beta cook I've ever met and
uh,
anyway,
so yeah,
that,
that's my dream is to put out one of
these a year.
That's a great idea.
And I mean really there's a lot of
amazing conversations that I've had with
people on this podcast that I would love
to see written down or I could read it,
go over it and let's not here my own
fun.
And also it's,
you people have in the bathroom,
you know,
it's like a little thing.
You just pick it up.
Whatever it is,
there's no,
you don't need to follow the flow or the
end.
You're encouraging reading,
which is a dying thing and people and in
there are a lot of people out there who
don't listen to podcasts.
Right.
Me included.
I rarely listen to podcasts.
Do you listen to books on tape?
No,
no,
no.
We'll see.
I don't have spaces in my life where I'm
doing something that would allow me to
listen to voices talking that wouldn't
interfere with what I'm doing.
So like,
yeah,
I'm not a carpenter.
I'm not driving long distances,
you know,
it's like I'm either writing or I'm
doing the doing my podcast or something
else,
but there's not,
I don't commute,
you know what I mean?
So,
so there's a specific sort of activities
that lend lend themselves to listening
to podcasts and a lot of people just
don't have those spaces in their lives.
So I envisioned the book is like
something where people can be like,
hey dude,
I know you don't listen to podcasts,
but this is why I do.
These are the sorts of crazy ass
conversations that Chris and Duncan and
Joe get into.
And that's why I like listening to those
guys,
you know,
or Wim Hoff or Graham Hancock and all
these guys are in the book.
Oh,
awesome.
Yeah,
yeah.
Man
Stopped.
I thought about it because before I
started doing the podcast,
I would listen to recordings of like
lectures at Terence Mckenna would give
or a timothy leary or you know,
and there wasn't a lot,
you know,
you or listen to art bell having some
weird,
a ufo expert on or something like that.
I mean,
that's really what you had to listen to.
You didn't have very many choices.
And then I think about all the
conversations that I've been able to
have with guys like John Anthony West
with Graham Hancock and Randall Carlson
and Michael Shermer and you and Duncan
and I mean so many people had these
crazy conversations with them.
That to me,
they've been.
I mean,
I,
it's shaped the way I look at
everything.
It's changed everything and so I feel
like I'm constantly getting educated,
you know?
Yeah.
You set up your life as like,
not,
I'm not talking about myself,
but you've had guests who are some of
the smartest people in the world who
come to you to sit here and chat with
you for,
you know,
I mean,
that's.
You have set up an amazing little
educational institution
here at times.
Sometimes it's education,
sometimes it's chaos,
but it's slow.
That's education certainly is.
You learned about what we're like when
we're drunk,
but it's what it is is it's a fan.
You know what I mean?
It's a thing and it's a thing that's
enjoyable to me.
Like A.
It's like I like having all these
conversations so if I can record them
and they just put them out there and
other people like them.
It's.
This is a very rare,
a balanced sort of relationship.
So to me there's no other way I'd get
like if I said to you,
Hey Chris,
let's sit
down and talk for three hours.
You'd be like,
I'm okay.
All right,
I'll block off three hours for you.
Can I look at my phone at all during
this time?
Can I get up to go to the bathroom?
We would never have this.
Like as connected a conversation,
I just got another set of headphones to
give to my guests because the
extensively.
The main reason is I'm using handheld
now because my whole thing is mobile
right below occasionally come to my
place in Topanga,
but normally I go to them and they can't
hear when they're not here,
so I have to keep like going,
hey,
the mic,
you know,
there are a lot of them.
They're not used to talking on Mike's
and all that,
but the other reason I got it is my
buddy kyle actually pointed out to me
that when you both have headphones,
you're both in a shared space and you're
much less likely to be thinking about
your phone or whatever because you're
both like,
I dunno what it does,
but it,
it seals it off in a way.
Yeah.
We talked about that yesterday.
Actually.
Me and Eddie Bravo talked about it
because he doesn't like to wear them
because he doesn't like the sound of his
own voice.
And I said,
well,
he and I are so comfortable.
We'd been friends for so long.
I didn't.
We didn't need to wear them,
but I feel like when you're having a
conversation with someone,
it cuts out everything else.
Right.
It's just youtube,
they're like,
there's no distractions in the room,
but if there were they would be less
distracting because the headphones.
Well that's the thing I'm out,
like sitting in a,
in a campsite somewhere by a river or
whatever.
There's a lot going on.
And the handheld microphone too.
It was a big thing and if you get a mic,
picks up everything,
then they pick up everything.
Everything.
Like they pick up some shit over by the
outhouse,
you'd hear in the background.
It was using a lapel mics for awhile,
but they were um,
the directional is too much and people
were complaining and like,
dude,
I can't in the car.
I can't hear you.
So I got the handheld.
It is an interesting thing,
right?
Because this is not something that it
production company would ever get
together and fund because they would say
if they did,
they'd have a sound guy and they'd have
a like half the fun is watching you.
Well,
will this one sock these,
these mikes are bullshit,
right?
We're not doing that anymore.
You know,
we've done a few from an iphone.
We used to do podcasts on a plane,
like we'd be,
you know,
me and Duncan are me and Ari or whoever
it was would be on a plane next to each
other.
I just take the iphone between us,
press record and start talking voice
notes and turn into a podcast and it's
not that bad.
Yeah,
I did that recently in the van.
I was driving.
I had some ideas.
I just grabbed my phone and started
talking into it and I threw it up.
People like it because they knew one
thing they know this is one of the
things that's appealing about podcasts
in general is that it's not produced
right.
It's just this is what it is.
You know?
It's like you've got an idea and I'm
getting it right from Chris Ryan's head.
It's going right from his head right in
that phone that's going right into my
ears.
There's nothing,
there's no filters.
There's getting right into your head.
It's one of the weirdest things about
podcasts in general,
is that the intimacy of your voice in
someone else's head,
like I'm sure when you meet them they
get weirded out.
Right?
A lot of people get really weird because
you got in their head and all of a
sudden you're right in front of them.
Hey,
like,
yeah.
And it's,
it's strange like they
know you,
but you know,
they really do know you.
It's not like fame where you're an actor
and people like,
Oh,
I know your face.
Like,
yeah.
But yeah,
I mean people really do know Joe Rogan.
Yeah.
Strangely.
So there are parts I know both of us
have parts of our lives we don't talk
about on the podcast specifically your
marriage.
I guess I don't like to talk too much,
but yeah,
I'm that way too.
I,
my impulse is to talk about everything.
Like on my impulse is like I got
nothing.
I got no secrets because I feel like
there's a,
like a revolutionary shamelessness.
Um,
you know,
I feel like I feel so privileged and
largely thanks to you and Duncan.
Honestly,
when I started the podcast and you guys
did that shrimp parade thing and that
really built up my audience and to the
point now where it paid,
it's self sustaining and it's my main
gig.
That's awesome.
It is awesome.
It's incredible.
But it's like,
I feel like there's a responsibility I
have in a way to express yourself
shamelessly because everybody else has a
job they can get fired from or a
marriage that they can get screwed.
The wife can leave them or they can.
I'm in vulnerable and so I kind of feel
like,
all right,
so the cost of that,
you know,
every opportunity or every privilege
comes with a responsibility.
The responsibility is like I got to talk
about shit that other people don't talk
about so that it's out there.
Right.
And so my impulse is to just say
everything,
you know,
and my sex life is really has been very
interesting and I'd like to talk about
it more,
but I don't want to,
you know,
other people never sort of said they
were down for that,
you know,
so
that too,
that's magnified when you have children
because they have no say,
well that's the vulnerability.
They put their kids out there and I'm
like,
well,
okay,
I'm not saying it's the worst thing to
do,
but it's not the child's choice.
And they're very young and you're making
a huge,
your look like whoever did what they did
to Michael Jackson,
right?
Yeah.
One of the things that they did is they
made him famous way before he had any
idea what the fuck that meant.
And they profited off of it.
Yeah.
They kind of pimped them out.
Right.
And that's kind of what's happened.
And I destroyed him,
but ultimately the whole thing destroyed
him.
Right.
And um,
I just,
I don't want to be a part of that.
there's no,
that's smart.
I don't think it's intelligent.
And I also don't,
this is my real honest feelings.
I do not think that fame is a.
I don't think that people should aspire
to it.
I think it should be something that
happens if people like your work and
then it's cool,
it's fine,
but I think there's way too much
emphasis put on just trying to get
attention and it's being rewarded and
supported in this weird way.
There's nothing wrong with getting
attention,
but it should make sense.
It should make sense.
There should be some reason.
And if it's out of balance,
you know,
you should,
you should probably look at like why?
Why is it out of balance.
Yeah.
And lots of things that attract
attention are not things that we need.
We,
we want more of,
you know,
like conflict.
Yes,
conflict.
That's a big one.
But it's also the.
I just fame itself.
One of the weirdest parts about it is
that you have to constantly be checking
yourself.
Like all these people are nice to you.
All these people are saying nice things
to you or being mean to you.
You know,
one of the like Dave,
all people that you don't even know,
so you can't rely on them for your self
esteem and you certainly can't rely on
them for criticism.
You can't rely on them.
People you don't even know that don't
care about you,
you know,
so you,
you,
you're in this weird position.
You have to be very careful with who you
communicate with because one of the
weirdest things you'll see from famous
people is all the sudden they get this
very strange thing where they feel like
people are supposed to do things for
them and you know,
they don't,
they're not supposed to pay for things
and everything's supposed to be easy and
they're supposed to get that.
That's a,
that's a weird one.
Like they don't respond to criticism.
Well,
they don't understand that they're still
a human being in the middle of growth.
No,
they're a fucking star.
I'm a fucking star and I want this and I
want it
now.
And they just like,
what kind of fucking bullshit is this?
Do you know who I am?
Yeah,
exactly.
We've seen,
we've all seen like a version of that
right about it.
The problem though is that they know
that their shit stinks.
Yes.
They know that they're human.
They know so they're.
So then they develop this sort of fraud,
a phobia that people are going to find
out what they really are.
I mean,
I've seen this with fashion models,
you know,
I used to hang out with a lot of fashion
models in Barcelona that,
you know,
that whole story where I lived in the
mansion with the fashion models.
Did you talk about that?
Could be,
I don't know.
I'm not sure,
but looking track of what the fuck we've
talked about possible.
It's impossible.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so uh,
yeah,
I fashioned model become fame,
wealth people who are extremely wealthy
and that gets back to the 70 grand a
year thing and the whole sort of
question of,
you know,
saturation,
what else it is,
it becomes a real problem with things
being too easy and life being like way
to a patterned like you.
Everything is very predictable in terms
of your success.
You have plenty of money.
You have a adulation from fans without
any stress or direct.
Are you going to have a little bit of
stress in terms of like trying to manage
your career,
but it's nothing like trying to make it
that.
I don't know if I'm ever going to make
it stress.
That's a totally different kind of
stress.
I don't know if I'm ever going to be a
success dress.
That's real shit that goes away once you
definitely become Kanye West or whoever
the fuck you are and then you're subject
to your own demons because then you're
alone.
You're really alone.
You can't even go to the grocery store.
You spend any time with Jim Carrey.
No,
I don't know.
I'd love to meet that guy.
He seems like he's in a weird stage of
his life.
He seems to me like someone who,
who you talked about,
you know,
you get to that pinnacle and you have to
deal with your demons.
Yeah.
It seems like he's dealt with them and
now he's come out the other side and
he's in this very sort of this place of
wisdom and uh,
and yeah,
it's,
I,
I just think he,
he sounded.
Russell brand is another guy who I think
I really admire what,
where they are in their lives and how
they got there.
They sort of went through the fire and
they've come out the other side somehow.
Rustled certainly has.
I know Russell,
he's,
he's a sweetie.
He really is a super sweet guy,
like genuine too and really trying to
like be a better person and a better
human and you know,
I don't agree with him on everything.
He gets a little social.
Justice warriors are on some things,
but I think it's just because he wants
to do good and he's like leaning towards
good and he's leaning towards love and
he's like,
it's all for the right reasons.
Like every,
even if I don't agree with them,
I see how he's thinking.
And even if I don't agree with Ms Dot
[inaudible] do not agree.
It's not a hard.
Do not agree.
It's.
Yeah.
He's a fascinating guy.
I think,
uh,
if Jesus came back,
he'd be Russell brand probably.
Fuck a few less checks.
Maybe Jesus would go just swinging dick
all over the place just to remove
everybody,
have their ego.
Everybody.
You don't possess these women.
Uh,
years ago I,
uh,
I came back from Asia,
I was in Asia for a couple of years and
I visited my best buddy in Paris and
we're throwing a football around.
I remember.
And some backstreet in Paris,
which freaked out the per regions of
course.
And my buddy's like the opposite of me.
He's religious,
he's disciplined,
he's speaks seven languages,
you know,
musical prodigy.
I'm a lazy fuck a girl growing up it was
like I was kirk,
he was spock,
you know,
is that kind of dynamic half your
audience wouldn't even know who we're
talking about it.
They're not sad.
But,
um,
he,
uh,
which explains why I've always wanted to
fuck a green woman that got this thing.
But uh,
he said it to me.
He's like,
Chris,
I figured you out man,
as what's,
what's the deal?
He said,
you're the anti monk,
said,
what do you mean?
He said,
monks cut themselves off from the
temptations of life in order to pursue a
spiritual path.
You're,
you're pursuing a spiritual path,
but it's by way of the temptations of
life.
You immerse yourself in them because in
those days I was doing a lot of drugs
and you know,
whatever.
And uh,
I think he's right.
And in Buddhism there is a path of the
drunken guru right the,
there,
there is a path of sex and altered
states of consciousness and sort of,
you know,
William Blake said the palace of wisdom
lies at the end of the road of excess.
You know?
And so someone like Russell brand,
I think that's his path.
He's gone through the,
the addictions and the orgies and all
that stuff that a lot of people think
would make them happy.
He's like,
check those boxes like now that didn't
do it in a way that very few humans ever
get to check them.
Family is a beautiful man and a
superstar.
And he came on the other side and became
this really conscious,
very spiritual person.
And very humble and a sweetie.
Nice guy.
I think humility is what you find if you
get through to the other side.
Yeah,
I think so.
I think if you.
But even when you get through the other
side,
it's like there's no,
there's no destination.
It's not like a spot you get to like
find that can relax.
I'm here.
Yeah.
Well he's used that phrase a minute ago.
Like,
you know,
trying to make it.
Yeah,
make it.
It's like it's as if you'll make it and
then you'll have it made,
you know,
like what,
what,
what did we make?
What's made that make it thing is really
for a comic is just this,
uh,
the high likelihood of success is always
looming over you.
And what is success?
Being able to flick special.
I'm not even just being able to work.
Just being a working,
working comedian.
Just paying your rent with your
standard.
That was always the dream.
Like every comic that starts out,
if they're being honest.
Fitzsimmons and I have talked about this
a hundred times because it was,
we'd never thought of a career.
I mean if it fits him is this one,
I think he's won at least two emmy's for
writing.
Brilliant guy and you know,
we were just two dorks to 21 year old
dorks hanging out together in Boston and
we did.
You were a fucking martial arts expert
in those.
A martial arts expert.
I was a Dork.
Dude.
I would get nervous talking.
I've talked about this.
I never could figure out why I freak out
when I would be about to talk to a bank
teller,
like walking up to.
I'd get like social anxiety.
I would know.
I was nervous.
It's not a good place to look.
Nervous.
Not.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
but back then it didn't make sense
because I was fighting and I would still
get nervous talking to like any person
who is in an official person,
any person,
like a teacher or a principal or anybody
that authority and authority figure.
I was super nervous talking to them,
but my wife gets out way around.
Anyone wearing a uniform freaks her out
because she was in a war when she was a
kid.
Oh Wow.
So like immigration guys.
She just,
she starts shaking and say workers.
Yeah.
No,
I hear you man.
Well,
uniform means uniform behavior,
right?
Uniform me.
Chicken goes sideways.
When's the last time you wore a tie into
uniforms?
Probably when I was taking the photos
for my 19,
99 cd cover,
real seedy.
I decided to dress like a,
like old school.
Frank Sinatra just decided when I.
When I made the CD,
I was thinking I never wear a tie and a
suit and a tie to be fun if I just
decided to wear a suit and a
tie for the cover of this.
So that's it right there.
That's probably brad pack the last time.
I'm going to be some day.
Yeah.
That's the theme song to my podcast is
you're going to die one day.
I don't want to give the end away,
but you're going to die one day.
That's a good song.
Carpet a fucking DMV.
Yeah.
Enjoy it.
I mean,
don't dwell on it too much.
I'll freak out.
You know?
Well,
it's like,
I think every young man should shave his
head like at 21 or something.
Shaved your head.
See yourself bald for a month or however
long it takes to grow back and it's
like,
okay,
that's it.
You're not going to worry about Ted's
though will say this,
but you have a normal head.
I don't know.
I've never shaved my head.
I have a friend.
It looks like his kid,
his parents never picked him up for the
first year and otherwise to just let
them lay down on a flat marble pillow.
His head is flat like a fucking pizza is
poor bastard on the top or the back of
it.
It's flat.
I think his parents just ignore the shit
out of him and he's got a flat head.
You know about the flathead Indians.
Which ones are those?
There was a up in Idaho that area.
Northern.
Yeah,
they,
they would put.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
They put a board on the baby's head
because the heads are so malleable and
then tighten it and they look like
coneheads,
like scare the fuck out of anybody.
I'm sure you saw those dudes riding up
war paint.
Flatheads.
And that was a thing about,
um,
some of the,
I think was it,
was it Peru where they would do,
they would find a lot of these skulls
from a certain period of time that had
been elongated and you know,
the alien people went nutty.
Like this is it,
this is evidence,
evidence of contact the aliens they've
been here,
but it's just boards.
They just put boards in the side of
their heads and stretched her heads up.
Yeah.
They think they might've even been
trying to emulate one of,
like,
originally the idea was bounced about
that someone in the royal family in
Egypt had deformities.
And that was one of the things that said
about king Tut.
Like King Tut was not a healthy person
like that.
He might may very well have been the
product of incest and that there was
some gender.
Do you remember reading about this?
Right?
Yeah.
I know about the incest in the options.
That some of the like heads when you see
people like with like,
hey,
elongated heads and hieroglyphs and
images,
they might have actually done that to
try to replicate someone who had
something fucked up to normalize it,
which might have been like a royal who
had been like look at their debts.
His head.
That's his actual head.
So on the left.
Yeah.
That's to tongue cut.
Is that his real head?
Peru,
Peru.
Oh,
these are giants
science goals.
But they have.
They have King Tut's head too though.
You see if you can google king Tut's at
the ones improved.
They know they're pretty like 90
with a high degree of certainty.
I don't wanna give you a number,
but that they use boards and and example
of that is in Spanish.
Look at what tufts had.
Must've looked like it was all fucking
weird.
It was all stretched out.
Like look at that.
Like if you saw,
if you saw that on the ship of a
spaceship on the deck,
like walking around and I'm like Oh my
God,
that's the alien.
Oh he must be from another planet.
Right.
Like if you were on a spaceship,
say if you watch star trek and that dude
walks by like,
well for sure that dude wants to be
playing someone from another Martini on
his head.
The top of his head is flat.
There's always an extra brain.
It looks like there's like 10 percent
extra brain.
Maybe more.
What?
What the fuck is going on back there?
Here's the flathead Indians.
This is a painting of Caitlin did at the
babies that would make you very non
aerodynamic.
You'd be like a land rover defender,
like a big flat square thing.
Similar schools though.
Oh Wow.
That normalizing crazy.
Looking in a royal weirdness.
You ever hear Spanish people speak?
They have the list.
Will they say that?
Because one of the kings had a list and
then all the court deers started
replicating it to seem cool.
You had told me about that and I had
forgotten when it came up the other day
when someone was bringing up a beat and
then.
Yeah.
And then I remembered it after the
podcast was over.
Yeah.
I don't know that that's true that.
I mean,
I haven't looked it up if it's
historically accurate or even if there's
a way to know because there are no
recordings.
Right.
Do you know the powdered wig one?
Do you know what?
No,
no.
That's the best.
Dad is a weird one that came from
syphilis.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
How?
Because men started getting syphilis,
find,
find out what year it was.
I forget what year.
We just brought it up recently,
but there was a royal family,
I think two brothers.
They both had syphilis and they started
losing their hair and a lot of men were
losing their hair to syphilis back then.
They just had it.
Nobody knew what the fuck it was.
Right?
So they would make wigs and the more
expensive,
more expensive the wig was,
the bigger would be.
So the really rich people would be big
wigs,
big wigs.
That's where big waves come from and
they literally put this style on to mask
the effects of syphilis.
Jesus,
it's a great story.
I didn't know syphilis made your hair
fell fall.
Fall.
Yeah.
You've teeth rot out.
You're falling apart,
man.
And your nervous system gets shoot
shooting.
You're rotten ges into somebody and
given it to them too.
And you don't even know what the hell's
going on.
Louis the 14th.
He was only 17 when his mom started
thinning.
Yeah.
So I'm 16,
Fifty five when the King of France
started losing his hair.
And so,
uh,
if you scroll down,
it goes into the,
the whole syphilis thing we get out.
So where,
where's the syphilis part mentioned?
Up above that.
He probably had buck and crazy.
Oh,
brother's head stuff.
Apparently everybody it back then.
And you just
imagine these people.
I mean they only lived to be 30.
The syphilis outbreak sparked a surge
and wig making victims hid their
baldness as well as bloody sores that
scoured their faces with wigs made out
of horse goat or human hair.
Perutz were also created a coded rather
with powder sentence with lavender or
orange to hide any funky aromas.
Although common wigs were not exactly
stylish,
they were just a shameful necessity.
So the King of France started losing his
hair and 1655.
And that's when everybody hopped on.
And his cousin Charles,
the second to the same thing,
both men likely had syphilis.
Syphilis created a whole,
like a thing where like judges would
wear those wigs,
powdered wigs.
They would look like they were
important.
People look at my wig,
you know,
we're doing right now.
Tribalizing right now.
Yeah.
So we're looking at our own culture,
British culture in this case,
but,
and,
and seeing how it's all this arbitrary
silliness.
And that's travel.
That's what travel does for sure.
You know,
because you see it in other cultures and
then you look back at your own and
you're like,
oh shit,
we do weird shit to fuck.
We're all weird.
There is no,
it's like the uh,
what is an Einstein right?
That there's no fixed point from which
to observe anything.
You're always on a moving.
Your perspective is always mobile.
So there is no objective truth.
Culturally it's,
it's all looking at one thing from
another thing in both of them are
moving.
Yeah.
I love that shit.
Because,
and again,
I think it leads to humility.
I think so too.
You know,
I think all roads lead to humility.
Ultimately,
it just leads to a greater perspective.
I mean if you live in a small town,
and I'm not knocking Ohio,
Jamie,
but if you live in a small town in Ohio,
that's what you're used to and you kind
of like develop your pattern of what you
expect to see in the world based on
what's around you in a,
in a very close,
immediate area,
but if you're in the fucking rain forest
to Bolivia and you're hanging out with
these tribal folks who are going to go
hunt a monkey and you're with them on a
monkey hunt and they're all excited,
they shoot this monkey out of a tree
with a bow and Arrow they made
themselves and then they're cooking this
monkey over a fire and throwing wet
leaves on it,
smoking it,
and you're like,
what the fuck?
And these people do this every day and
they're going to die in this forest.
I mean,
this is what they.
This is what they do.
This is how they live.
And for you it's like I gotta get Outta
here.
For them,
this is like,
this is the small town in Ohio.
There's just a small town in Ohio in the
jungle like this.
To them,
this is their world and maybe
interestingly for you,
it isn't.
I gotta get Outta here.
Maybe it's like this is where I should,
should have been my whole life.
There are thousands of cases of people
from civilization running away to go
native.
There are no historical cases that I
know of where native people have chosen
to come and live in civilization.
Yeah.
I hate to beat a dead horse because I
always it with Sebastian Junger's
tribe is amazing book.
I really enjoyed that.
I talk about too much.
It's one of those things.
It's good to me.
It's uh,
it is really good.
I've read it three times.
It's a short book.
Yeah,
it's one of,
it's uh,
it covers a lot of the same ground that
I cover in civilized to death.
Actually.
I quote him in civilized to death and
some of them we have some of the same
sources,
but yeah,
he looked at some of the,
that uh,
those accounts of people running away to
go live with the natives and it makes
sense.
Totally makes sense.
Like a dog you ever read?
Um,
call of the Wild Jack London.
London,
yeah.
It's a school.
It's a very good book and it's about a
husky who goes and lives with the
wolves.
It's essentially the story of the
domesticated being going and living with
the wild iterations of that same being,
right?
So it's like one of us and going to go
live in the Amazon or whatever.
There's a fantastic book if you like.
That kind of thing is at play in the
fields of the Lord.
I've heard that,
but I never read that one book,
man.
Peter Matheson.
That's a book,
right?
Isn't there?
Probably 30 years old,
maybe more.
And it was made into a film starring
down Daryl Hannah and Tom Waits.
And uh,
who else?
John Lithgow,
Kathy Bates.
Incredible,
incredible cast.
There's something that you get from
escaping civilization that you,
if you don't know,
you're missing it until you're out
there.
When you're out there,
and I'm sure you experienced this in
your travels,
there's,
there's a certain detachment from the
masses,
like just just just to be out of the
hive and the influence of all the people
around you.
As weird as it seems,
there's this energy that we're all
exchanging and these giant hives
together and some people live off of it
like those New York City people like my
friend Jeff lives in New York City is
always going to live in New York City.
This is what I like.
He likes it.
I love it.
He's walking through the street punk.
Bam,
Bam.
Yes.
That's his thing.
To me,
I'm like,
wow,
I'm always my.
My thought is always,
how do you guys do this?
How do you guys do this?
That's all I ever think.
How the fuck do you guys do this for him
is how could you live any other way,
but the people that.
But he has got a good life,
so he's got.
He enjoys what he does.
He's a fulfilled life.
He's happy,
but if you didn't think were talking
about the same thing I'm talking about.
Jordy,
have you ever had got it?
Nepal.
Oh,
it hurts.
Rough.
Your farts smell really interesting when
you might've got a.
got a too bad because I have a friend
who got really bad where he's sick in
the hospital for like two days.
Yeah.
I didn't go to the hospital by that
point.
I had been traveling for a few years.
You already.
I've had hepatitis.
I mean I've had some.
I've had to,
you know.
Yeah.
I spent three days in a room in Polinsky
shitting and puking into the same
plastic bag.
Oh boy.
Three days in the same
bag.
What is it like after day three?
If you had the worst enemy?
It was day one.
Matthew.
On the third floor.
There's worst enemy was just standing
there smoking a cigarette.
Would you drop that bag on the mother?
Mercy.
I don't have any enemies that.
Yeah,
you'd have to really hate somebody for
that.
One of the funniest thing about that was
I came out of that room after I.
It might've been two days.
I don't know,
but it came out of that room,
you know,
Pale,
emaciated,
just totally drained and I went out on
the terrorists of this Pelinka ever been
there.
Oh,
amazing.
Mayan Ruins and lots of magic mushrooms.
Once I hit one to teach an Eatsa,
a teaching school teaching,
he says,
much more sort of commercialized only
case.
Pretty wild stuff.
Taloon was another one that's out on its
own or is that my hands mindset?
Both money.
Anyway,
I come out and there's this woman there,
this German woman,
and we start chatting a little bit and
she,
and this was at a time in my life where
I was really nervous around women and
whatever,
and this woman was like super into me
and I was like,
I was like,
I could not fuck you.
Like I just,
there's no,
I didn't do much.
I just saw it was,
felt so sick and horrible and it turned
out later.
I got to know her a little bit.
She was really into punk music and she
thought I looked like johnny rotten.
So she thought you were cute because you
looked at John Ross.
I looked like I was about to die.
That was the end of that.
Look for people out there that you might
go camping.
Please just get a gravity filter.
Don't get Giardia.
You can.
It's really easy.
It's real and there's also a thing
called a steri pen.
Steady parents.
Wonderful.
Take the Steri pen.
You run it around in the water for a
certain amount of time and it kills
everything bad in the water and you even
taste it doesn't taste any different.
It's literally like UV light.
There's a bunch of like stereo pens,
a good one,
but these gravity filters are amazing
and they have pumps.
They have another one.
You can take some water and you pump it,
you pump it and it goes through the
filter into your water bottle and you
can drink it.
You can clean up all like 99 point nine,
nine percent of all the bullshit with
just a good filter and it doesn't.
You don't have to drop the chemicals in
there.
Some people bring those.
Yeah,
I have a tablet and stuff like that,
but you don't need to,
but please don't drink at a creek folks.
It could be dead yards up.
I don't know if you.
If you pull this up,
I just recently I read a thing online
saying that like it's almost never
necessary to filter your water when
you're in when you're camping,
and I've always filtered my water
camping,
but it was this thing where they did all
these.
They took all these samples of creeks
from creeks and and like apparently
they're like self correcting mechanism
nature,
but if something's dead hundred yards
up,
you're fucked.
If you don't want that,
it's not worth it.
The gravity filter so fucking easy.
It's like if you.
You could take the risk and shit your
brains out for three days or you can
just enjoy with water
from the same place.
I think shitting your brains out for
three days is a good experience.
Yeah.
It's like an ordeal.
Poison,
right?
Yeah.
Do you ever get high from vomiting?
No.
Have you?
Yeah.
Whoa.
Because when you vomit,
you get all these endorphins.
You don't feel great after you vomit.
I felt better.
Yeah,
go with gray.
It's true.
I'm relatively great.
Last time I did some serious vomiting
because I had food poisoning,
but I guess I was about 10 years ago I
had some pretty serious food poisoning.
It was just hurl anatomy.
That was the last real,
real like unstoppable.
Yeah.
Well it's just coming out and just a fat
tube of it.
You ever have a colonic irrigation?
No,
not into things going in my,
but I don't believe.
I don't believe that that is necessarily
a healthy thing either.
I don't believe it's not that it's,
but this all the stuff that people
saying that it's healthy for you.
I'm like,
I don't necessarily think it is a while
about that.
You know,
I sent you an email about him.
Actually,
he's.
He's like,
you know what?
I am the big beard.
He's a fan of yours.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
I was.
I was with him in Tucson and he,
he saw,
he's an old friend of Paul stamets.
He was at Harvard.
Yeah,
I can.
I'll hook you up.
He is.
He ever comes to La.
He's,
he was the most famous doctor in America
for years.
He,
he,
um,
but he's really interesting because he
was at Harvard with leary.
He studied under Richard Evans.
Shelties is undergrad degrees in botany.
Richard Evans,
shelties as the guy who basically
discovered in Camas,
hundreds of psychoactive plants in the
Amazon,
you know,
amazing dude.
Anyway,
um,
so andrew was right in the mix and he
sort of was central in leary getting in
trouble because Andrew wrote an article
in the Harvard Crimson criticizing leary
for indiscriminately giving psilocybin
to students.
And that's what triggered the Tom after
that.
Anyway,
Andrew went onto Harvard med school,
residency at mass,
this mass general in Boston,
like top top flight academic stuff,
but instead of he got his md but then he
went and worked at the National
Institutes of health in Bethesda,
Maryland,
the main government research center.
So like early seventies I think.
And he has never wavered in his
understanding that drugs are not
necessarily bad.
And so he did these double blind studies
about marijuana.
The first,
I believe double blind studies of
marijuana where he said like,
okay,
you know,
people have tested marijuana and they
say,
oh,
it's bad for your brain because what
they do is they get people high who've
never been high and then they give them
a bunch of math questions and they have
trouble.
I can answer them whenever he's like,
I've been high,
I don't want to do math when I'm high,
so let's test people on things they like
doing when they're high,
like color perception or pattern
recognition or ability to recognize
tonal changes in music,
things like that.
And he found that their perceptions were
actually heightened.
So it's like,
ah,
see,
marijuana is not bad.
It's just bad for certain things and not
others.
So then he did,
um,
I think it was about driving.
We said,
okay,
they find that marijuana impacts impairs
driving ability,
but that's again,
because they're using naive people
who've never been high before and they
don't have a chance to practice driving
while high.
So he got people let them practice,
let them get used to being high.
Then he tested their driving ability
versus what it had been before or when
they're not stone and average scores and
all that,
and he again,
he found that when people had a chance
to practice,
they drove fine.
There's no problem.
He got basically pushed out because he
was finding,
you know,
he was demonstrating that it's not
necessarily a bad thing.
Yeah.
It's one of those things that we talked
about before.
Sometimes people don't want to know the
actual results.
They just want to know the results that
jive with their understanding of this is
really dangerous in science because
people are purporting to be objective
and sign off and they're not.
And it's not fair.
It's not fair to all the people that
were unjustly arrested and prosecuted
and imprisoned for something that's very
beneficial.
And they were saying a lot of them
saying that they like it,
saying that it does good things for
them.
You know,
it's not the end all cure all,
but there's not a goddamn thing it is,
but it's certainly a tool.
Right.
And look at it objectively,
what,
what's the ratio of benefit to danger?
Right.
You know,
how many people have died from marijuana
overdose?
Zero ever.
Right?
And so Andy Wilde has been saying this
since the seventies and his first book
is called the natural mind that he wrote
the marriage of the sun and the moon
than a book called from chocolate to
morphine.
These are all big stretch,
but chocolate is a drug,
right?
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
And the marriage of the sun and the
moon.
Each chapter is about a mind altering
substance or experienced.
So vomiting is one chapter in there.
Cocaine,
mushrooms.
So he and Paul stamets had been buddies
for 35 years.
There's,
does that have anything to do with
bulemia?
Does bulemia also like something where
people are getting addicted to actual
throwing up?
Yeah.
And there are religions where people
vomit every morning in India.
I think Gandhi vomited every morning.
Jesus Gandhi and he drank his own pissed
by the way.
Way to go.
Yeah.
So anyway,
Andy Weil is this kind of hippie doctor
dude with all the drugs and all that,
and the big white beard.
And then he,
um,
he became very famous in the eighties
with books about alternative medicine,
but he goes complimentary medicine
because he's not saying Western
medicine's bad,
he's
saying it's good for some things,
not the best approach to other things.
So he brings in Ayervetic and Chinese
and all these different traditions,
depending on what the issue is.
He became very mainstream,
huge mega bestsellers on Oprah cover of
Time magazine,
you know,
he started a school at the University of
Arizona for doctors to get a
certification in complimentary medicine.
So He's super mainstream,
successful,
but he has never wavered on his stance
on drugs.
And so imagine the pressures that were
coming on them believable.
And he's like,
no,
fuck it.
The seventies and the eighties.
All that say no to drugs era.
Here's a question that you'd probably
know the answer to.
Um,
there are obviously killing untold
numbers of rhinos for their horns
because men want to grind them up and
it's supposed to get your dick hard.
Does that work for me?
Did you try it and have it out there
killing rhinos on the snake pit forever?
You know,
is there any science to that?
No,
not that I'm aware of.
That is the craziest genocide ever.
And who's doing it?
It's not Africans who think it's gonna
make their dicks hard.
It's Chinese.
It's Asian people that apparently have
a.
What I was told is that it's not even
necessarily just about the idea that it
gets your dick hard,
but there is value in the fact that it's
a forbidden thing that's very difficult
to acquire.
I think that's.
I think it's a signaling.
It's like a Rolex watch or a Lamborghini
or whatever.
It's like what my friend told me it was
that it's not just a signaling,
but it's a signaling that you don't give
a fuck.
Like you're,
you're here to make money and get the
best and have the best things.
And look what's,
let's drink rhino t and then we're gonna
eat shark fin soup.
Ha can live.
Monkey brain.
Have you seen that?
I've seen that.
That's really intense.
That's real.
I've sought in um,
a faces of death.
A bunch of people sitting around there
whacking a monkey in the head with a
hammer and his head stuck in this little
thing,
but I was in the table.
Yeah.
I wasn't really sure if that was real
and they scoop it out.
And you didn't.
Yeah.
Rattlesnake brains though,
isn't that like prions?
Can you get prions from primate brains?
Like you can.
You could be deathly ill from that.
Right?
Like that's essentially what mad cow
diseases.
Yeah.
From brains.
Chow,
forcing cows,
eat cows.
That's where mad cow disease comes from,
which is a body mind couldn't give blood
because he was in England.
He lived in England during the time that
the mad cow.
I was in Spain then.
Yeah.
I can't give blood because of the
hepatitis A.
Which one did you get?
A,
B or c?
A.
Is that a good one?
Yeah,
that's the,
that's the one is easy one.
Oh yeah.
It was like a month down yellow eyes,
like no energy a month.
That was,
yeah.
That,
uh,
that's a long story,
but that,
that I actually got it from a guy who
was sort of saving me from something
else that I,
they never told you the whole Scorpion
and Guatemala story.
I think he did.
But tell me again.
Well,
it's a long story.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know though.
People will be well feel like they're
getting now people can hear it.
I,
I've told her it on my podcast and I've
also,
I told her it on a podcast called risk
and that's actually cliff notes.
Uh,
yeah,
but listen to the risk thing,
if anyone wants to hear the whole thing
because they added sound effects and
it's really good.
What is risk?
It's a,
it's a podcast or just,
it's a storytelling thing,
you know,
it's like the moth,
it's that kind of thing.
And they added sound effects.
Yeah.
They produced it really well.
As well to.
Yeah.
What happened was I was,
I was with my girlfriend at the time,
Puerto Rican,
super beautiful Puerto Rican girl,
and she tried to get you to go to a camp
away and talk about Jesus or no,
she never tried to talk to me about
Jesus,
but I would have listened because she
was interested in how the APP.
No,
she was great.
Um,
so I was with her in Guatemala and uh,
we had met this other couple,
solange and Fabrizio and um,
yeah,
we were at this place called t carl in
North East Guatemala,
way,
way back in the jungle and it's a mayan
ruins,
beautiful,
crazy,
you know,
it was like a big city and now they're,
when I was there,
this was 1989,
there were maybe 10 big ruins,
big temples that they had uncovered.
And we're staying in this campsite with
hammocks.
It was very primitive at the time.
Anyway,
uh,
we,
it was a full moon and on,
and I decided we were going to take some
acid and watch the moon rise and the sun
set up from the top of symbol for,
it's called the Jaguar temple.
And so we went up with this other couple
and there's this ledge up there and it's
up above tree line,
you know,
you're way above the tree line.
You can see the monkeys,
the monkeys and,
and like see out over this flat jungle
Putin,
I think it's called.
And um,
so we're up there and the sun's sinking
and the moon is rising and the moon
comes up.
It's beautiful.
And,
and there's this big bank of storm
clouds and the full moon is like between
the horizon and the storm clouds.
But then it starts to go up behind these
clouds and you can see it's going to get
dark as fuck.
Right?
So this other couple were like,
yeah,
we're going to go back to the campsite.
They didn't know we were tripping.
Right.
And we timed it.
So we were peeking like now you know,
and so they're going to go back to the
campsite.
So we,
but we were like,
yeah,
we're gonna just hang here.
Right.
So I went over to hold the flashlight
for them as they went down this ladder
and was like maybe a 30 foot ladder pipe
ladder drilled into the temples,
made out
of limestone blocks.
And so to get up there.
Yeah,
there you go.
Before.
So we're at steep.
Yeah.
Is that climbed up at temple for though?
I mean,
uh,
the,
the Jaguar temple.
I typed in temple for Jaguar.
Oh,
okay.
Cool.
Yeah,
yeah.
When I was there was much more
overgrown.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so we,
we went up to the top of that.
Looks like if they're on the right.
Yeah,
that looks like it from like when we
were there anyway.
So we're up on that ledge there and,
and see how flat the jungle is.
Just goes forever.
It's so crazy how it's almost like
uniform and height.
Yeah.
I mean just very,
very little bit,
but.
Oh look at that picture.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
It looks like a picture I took actually
up there.
Anyway,
so looking.
It's so beautiful.
So we're up there and uh,
and I'm holding the ladder for these
guys going down and they're like,
okay,
we're good.
I'm like,
okay.
I turned off the ladder and I take a
step and fuck.
Oh,
what the fuck was that?
I turned the flashlight back on.
See the Scorpion going up the wall,
stirring up the wall like four inches
green,
and then they're like three other ones
on the wall and say,
fuck this things crawling with fucking
scorpions.
And I just got stung on the toe while
you're on acid while I'm tripit and
thank God I didn't jump because I would
have dropped 30 feet to fucking rocks.
Oh my gosh.
So I go back to Anna and she said,
what happened to you?
I said,
I just fucking Scorpion.
Like,
watch out.
And like,
oh,
Jesus,
right?
Oh my God.
So we're kind of like,
oh,
are they dangerous?
I don't know.
So I'm now it's getting dark,
right?
Because the moon's going behind these
clouds and there's this other,
these two dudes like way over on the
other side of the ledge and we go over
to them and they're Italian and they
don't speak English,
but he spoke Spanish,
so she was talking to them in Spanish
and Italian and you sort of understand,
you know,
they're both Latin,
similar languages and those guys are
like,
ah,
I don't know.
And we were like,
watch out because they're all around
like,
oh shit.
Yeah.
So while we're talking to them now it's
totally dark.
This Guatemalan dude comes up the ladder
with an old bolt action rifle and he's
like the night guard or something.
So we go over to him and honest as to
him in Spanish is in some Scorpio and
they got,
are they dangerous?
The Scorpions and the guy says csun like
Dolly's,
I'm worth those.
They're lethal.
There are deaths.
Like,
ah,
fuck man,
I understood enough Spanish to get that.
You're thinking you're dying.
So I'm like,
this.
Is it?
April,
full moon of April 1989.
Yeah,
I was 27.
It was right around time of trump's
plane
crashed.
What if it was exactly the same?
I think.
Talk about being curious in your life.
Yeah.
I was at a table that Puerto Rican girl
while you were would that other Puerto
Rican girl up there?
Puerto Rican girls crossed our paths.
Both survived.
She was barely.
So what happened to you?
So I'm thinking like,
fuck,
I gotta get down from here because
there's no way anyone else could carry
me down these ladders and you couldn't
get a stretcher down.
Right?
So if I'm going to survive,
I got to get down on my own quickly.
So then if I collapse they can get an
ambulance.
Although we're like,
you know,
two days from Guatemala City and
whatever the town was,
I don't even know if they had a clinic
or I don't know,
but we were pretty remote and I'm like,
they're not going to send out a
helicopter or some shit like that.
Right.
So,
uh,
I get down.
I.
Oh,
so what happens is my girlfriend's
freaking out.
No,
no criticism of her.
I think it's much harder to watch
someone you love die than to die
yourself and in this case.
And so she's like,
Oh fuck,
you're dying.
And I'm thinking,
Gee,
uh,
maybe.
And so the one of the Italian dudes was
like,
look,
you guys go,
I'll stay with her and you know,
make sure she's all right.
And so I go down with his other Italian
dude.
We go down the ladder and we get down to
the floor and we start walking around
the jungle and it's fucking totally dark
now because the moon's totally obscured.
And the jungle,
you know,
when you're tripping,
you're,
your pupils are super dilated so you can
see light and stuff that normally you
might miss.
Like the jungle in Guatemala was full of
glowing worms and shit flying by.
It's all like green and blue and.
Yeah.
And they're like these caterpillars and
like,
Holy Shit,
this place is wild.
So we're walking around,
lost.
Totally dark tripping.
I'm tripping.
He doesn't know.
How,
how trip and are you tripping?
That was three head nods,
ladies and gentlemen.
I mean,
you know,
I'm peeking from the acid plus all the
adrenaline,
right?
And so this pain is running up my leg
and as it's like running up my,
the bone in the center of the leg,
just kind of fire.
And when it gets to the top of muscles,
seize up,
you know,
my from the knee down,
it's just like rigid.
And then my tongue starts swelling and
my throat starts swelling.
And I got this like novacane feeling in
my lips and I'm sort of drooling and um,
and I'm thinking when this gets to my
heart,
that's when I die.
And so I'm,
I'm with this guy and we're lost.
And,
and at first like I'm freaked,
I'm scared and then it occurs to me that
I'm saying my last words to a guy whose
face I've never seen because we didn't
shine the light in his face when we're
talking to him and he doesn't understand
English.
And that cracks me up that I just,
I start laughing like a fucking maniac
and he's like,
got his arm around me.
He thinks I'm like losing it.
And I'm just like,
this is hilarious.
And I think about my friends and how
they're going to be like,
yeah,
you know,
good on Chris,
he,
he didn't die in some dumb ass way.
Like we all thought he would get.
He died in this.
It's still a dumb ass way,
but at least it's interesting.
And then I started thinking,
you know,
all right,
I'm 27,
but I've been around the world.
I literally around the planet,
I've been in love.
I've had sex with gorgeous women who
loved me,
who,
you know,
I've,
Wa,
I,
I made a shit ton of money.
I walked away from it.
I,
I've done,
I've done everything I wanted to do.
I'm 27,
but I've done everything and I've had a
fucking amazing life.
Wow.
And this is cool.
I would have been crying like a bitch,
I believe.
No,
you know,
I felt really bad for my parents and,
and Ana.
But for myself,
I was like,
I've had a good fucking run.
It's not as long as I would've liked,
but I've had a good fucking run.
So I really came to this piece and like,
the world doesn't owe me shit,
man.
I've had.
I mean,
I had been in Alaska two summers at that
point.
I worked in New York in Manhattan for
two years at that point with a guy who
offered me a million dollars if I would
stay.
And I said No.
And I left.
I flew to India.
I had been in Asia for two years.
You've said no to a million bucks when I
was 26.
Why did you say no to the million bucks?
What was the catch was you need to do
to,
you know,
he was a really good guy actually.
Uh,
I liked him a lot.
The million bucks was,
he said when you're 30 you'll have a net
worth of a million dollars and if you
don't,
I'll write you a check for the whatever
you're missing and we'll notarize it and
this guy's worth $30,000,000
or something.
So he just wanted you to work for him.
He wanted me to stay and I wanted to go.
I wanted to see the world and this guy
hired me to help him manage his family's
property in midtown Manhattan and the
main reason he hired me is because I
didn't give a shit about money,
so he knew I wouldn't steal from him.
Ah,
that's interesting.
And then when it stopped being fun and
knew,
I was like,
I got to go.
He's like,
no,
stick around.
I'll make it worth your while.
And so there was this weird dynamic.
But anyway,
I had all these experiences and so I
would wear a piece.
I like,
Hey,
I've had a good run.
So
anyway,
we finally,
we,
we come out into this little parking lot
and there's this Guatemalan kid there
maybe 10 or something and the Italian
guy talks to him and says,
Scorpion,
Scorpion.
And the kid looks at me like,
oh my God,
come,
come.
And he takes us to this trailer and we
bang on the door and this horrible
fluorescent light comes on.
And this like Guatemalan Dude who
obviously had been drunk and asleep,
you know,
it was like the kid says he's the
doctor.
He's not a doctor.
He's some jungle dude,
whatever,
and the,
so the guy takes us in and he's talking,
you know,
it's sort of Saki,
broken English,
and I explained to him,
he says,
how big is the Scorpion?
He looks at my foot.
He says,
how big was the Scorpion?
I say,
yeah,
like this big,
like a finger and what color?
Gray,
green sort of.
And he says,
ah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's not a scorpion.
That's electron.
So in Spanish and that part of
Guatemala.
Anyway,
they're two different words.
A squat beyond is a little red thing.
Electron is a big green thing,
but they're both with the tail and the,
you know.
And uh,
so we had been using the word Scorpion
because in English that's all there is.
But Scorpion,
Scorpion in that part of Guatemala is
lethal and that's a little tiny thing.
That's a little red thing and that'll
fucking take you out.
But the guys like,
look,
you're still,
this was two hours ago and you're still
alive.
You'll be fine.
Apparently it's like if you have a bad
heart or you're a kid,
maybe this will kill you.
But if you're,
if you survive a couple hours,
you're going to be speaking to something
I've read today.
Something about the Atkins Guy.
This is an interesting story.
You know,
the Atkins Diet.
It's very controversial because diet is
a lot of protein stuff.
Um,
I had heard that the guy died of a heart
attack and that they weren't being
completely honest as apparently even
snopes says it's not clear the guy had,
he felt like he was the head of like,
it's so weird when this happens.
The Atkins Diet Guy,
when he died,
he weighed 258 pounds,
so he was overweight and he was 72 years
old.
And the story was that he slipped on ice
in front of his house and hit his head.
Um,
but he also had a history of heart
disease.
I did not know that.
And he had had heart attacks.
Is that why he got into the research
that led to the Diet?
I don't know.
Just read that today.
I'm like,
there's some conspiracy in was it was a
Vegan guy who was talking about it,
but there's a conspiracy about adkins
and that Atkins really died from a heart
attack,
which would ruin the brand when that
found he was 258 pounds.
I was like,
wait,
how weight?
That's heavy.
How tall was he?
The report concludes,
uh,
Dr Atkins 72 at a history of heart
attack and congestive heart failure and
notes that he weighed 258 pounds at
death.
Yeah.
So he was really unhealthy,
which is really interesting because that
whole diet,
the Atkins Diet,
like a lot of people were really
criticizing that diet and saying that
it's really terrible and all the fat and
all this stuff to all the protein you
eat,
you really shouldn't eat that much.
But it's very similar to what a lot of
people are eating now when they're
eating Paleo and they're eating low
carb.
Apparently.
The real problem within our read this
today about fat,
high fat diets is if you're going to eat
a high fat diet and must be a low carb
diet as well,
you cannot have high,
high fat and carbs that is really bad
for you because your body's going to use
all the carbohydrates for fuel and all
the fat that you eat.
It's just going to be stored and
apparently that combination,
especially with saturated fats is very
bad.
So you want to be ketogenic or or you
want to be close to it,
you know,
you wanna,
you essentially want to eliminate most
of the stuff that people love.
Pizza and bread and pasta eliminate
almost all that stuff.
That's just all those unnatural foods,
but the point being that I'd never heard
that.
I've always heard that he had fallen and
I'd assumed that anything other than
that would be a conspiracy theory,
but then I read that and I was like,
whoa.
You know who wrote it?
Now remember John Joseph from the Cro
mags.
You know that guy's a Vegan,
super healthy,
ultra marathon,
a triathlon dude.
Now he used to be.
We still is lead singer,
the chromatics.
I think they're still around.
I know he tore.
Still might be torn on his own now,
but he wrote that about Atkins today.
I was on.
Yeah.
Well,
just to tie this together.
The guy after he explains this to me,
he gives me a couple pills,
probably aspirin or something and he dip
some water out of a bucket and says,
take these pills.
You'll be fine.
I'd been traveling a long time.
I knew you don't drink water out of a
bucket and the tropics,
but this guy just told me I wasn't going
to die,
so I'll do whatever the fuck he says.
And I drank the water and a week later
and hepatitis.
Wow.
You got the hepatitis hepatitis from a
bucket of this dude had laying around as
dirty shed.
That's crazy.
Exactly.
And that's.
You narrowed it down to that particular
moment that you got hepatitis,
but I assume,
I mean that's a pretty high risk for.
Yeah.
Fucking crazy people with their guts
biome down there.
You know,
they can.
It's like if you see other animals drink
out of a puddle,
do you freak out?
No.
Yeah,
like a dog drinks out of public,
you know,
freak out because the dog's got bodies
going to handle that.
Well,
that's what Jeff Leach was telling me
about the Hudson.
They drink right out of mud puddles all
the time.
It's like,
you know,
that's why he wanted their microbiome.
Yeah.
We have a weak ass bitch ass
preservative laden microbiome
antibiotics.
You can avoid them.
It's hard to stay alive,
you know,
if you get really,
really,
really sad.
No,
I'm not talking about medical.
I'm talking about in the food supply,
the water supply.
They're everywhere in America.
I don't know if that really affects us
that much.
They.
One of the things that I was.
I don't think there's levels of
antibiotics in the water supply that's
really affecting us.
It's possible that some of it is getting
to us in the food supply,
but more so than not,
I think the issue is poor dietary
choices because poor dietary choices are
the number one factor and what affects
your microbiome.
Super Low fiber,
low fiber.
Just not just not eating healthy.
If you're eating a lot of sugar in
particular,
you've got candida running around your
gut and they,
the unhealthy bacteria reacts better to
that and your body starts craving it.
That's one of the weirdest things about
when you do eat a low carb diet is your
body's really doesn't crave
carbohydrates anymore.
It's like it's a trick,
but when you're on carbohydrates,
if you eat them a lot and your body's
craving them all the time,
it's like you are being influenced by
those organisms that are in your
digestive tract,
which is really freaky.
Yeah,
I mean that's the whole sort of super
organism.
I think you and I've talked about that
in the past,
the idea that w toxoplasmosis you know
about that she says these things that
get into the brain and determine
behavior and from the gut as well can
determine.
I mean,
not even something as simple as a simple
example of like wanting,
wanting the organism to crave the thing
that,
that works for them,
but not for the organism,
but man,
that weird,
like really complex behaviors that are
created by some parasites in the brain,
you know,
like cats that are,
are mice that aren't afraid of cats and
are actually attracted to the smell of
cat piss.
Sexually attracted.
Yeah.
They get turned off.
It's crazy.
And that,
that bacteria or this toxoplasmosis can
only grow and it can only reproduce
inside a cat's gut.
Right?
Which is fucking bananas.
Like Paul Ski,
we,
Paul,
Ski Roberts,
he's great and he went into depth about
that and it's just,
it's one of those things where you just
stop and go.
What?
He's a cool guy.
I remember mentioning him to you once on
this podcast and Jamie brought up is his
photo and you looked at his photo and
you said there's a guy who does not give
a fuck if you look at it was crazy
fucking hair ponytail.
He's homeless.
He's just,
he's interested in the work here yet.
Yeah.
The work,
yeah,
but he was gracious enough to give us an
hour there.
He is right there for a super nice guy
too,
but just A.
I mean his work with baboons as well.
It was covered in a radiolab podcast is
fascinating podcasts with the observed
like this baboons is temporary baboo in
utopia where.
Yeah,
you and I talked about that where the
upper ranking males
eight,
the contaminated meat and died out.
Yeah.
I love that story.
It's one of the only hopeful fucking
stories out there.
Well,
I feel like there's certain pockets of
humanity like,
I mean I've never been to burning man,
but I assume that that's sort of a
representation of that as well.
Certain pockets of humanity were
likeminded people get together and they
say,
well,
it doesn't have to be like this,
like just because we're all caught up in
this crazy trap and I think more of
those little pockets of humanity are
popping up day in,
day out.
I think this podcast represents that and
a lot of way to,
you know,
we're talking about the podcast being a
cult of its own creation in in some way,
but I think it's more of a community.
Well no one's asking you to do anything
and there's no,
there's no,
you know,
there's no rules,
but it's,
it's an opportunity for likeminded
discussion that's rarely present in
cubicle life.
When I think about,
I mean podcasts are in the intro to
this,
this podcast book we were talking about
earlier,
I said that I think that podcasting is
on a par with the invention of the
printing press in terms of the potential
for radical social change because
there's no,
like you said before,
there's no filter.
There's nothing between you and your
audience and that's a radical thing.
I mean the printing press said w when
the printing press came about,
what that meant was you didn't need to
have a team of scribes to copy out this
thing that you've written.
Right?
Right.
So you can be just a regular guy and pay
the thousand bucks or whatever the
equivalent of that was in medieval
Europe.
And have all these pamphlets printed so
you could be Martin Luther and change
the world if you have a good idea and it
takes hold.
Podcasting seems similar to that in in,
in the sense that anybody who can afford
a few mikes in a laptop can get their
message out and if it catches fire,
it catches fire it and it goes around
the world.
You could do it on a phone to look.
We're saying you don't really need a
whole lot of equipment.
A lot of people use one of those small
mp3 Mike's a zoom.
We use that early on.
I still use a zoom.
Yeah,
I
see.
I think maybe I think you probably.
You're onto something.
I think the Internet in general and the
ability for people to just create their
own content,
that's the real.
The gatekeepers to the masses have
always been these production companies,
content provider's networks,
all these people,
the hallowed halls and those people all
got fat on it and a weird way because
the gatekeepers are the ones that
hoarded all the money and then they gave
some of the money to the actors and some
of the money to the writers and
everybody got wealthy,
don't get me wrong,
but the gate,
the Harvey Weinsteins of the world is
the one that really got rich.
If you look at that guy like that guy is
the guy that really got rich and really
happy to,
oh,
he's doing really well.
He's doing super.
That's great.
He,
I mean obviously that guy's the worst
example,
right?
But he obviously also on a positive
note,
financed a lot of amazing movies and if,
if it wasn't for him,
they wouldn't have gotten done.
But clearly those people that do that,
there are different thing.
They're business people now is the first
time ever that there's a direct
connection between a guy like you and a
guy like whoever's listening to this
right now,
that's never happened before.
I mean the only one in the room,
you know,
we have Jamie helping out and then it
goes to the server and then it's
uploaded to the rss feed and then it
goes to itunes and it goes to wherever
the fuck you're getting your podcast
from and that's it.
There's no steps.
There's no network,
there's no notes,
there's no production.
Meaning if you did your podcast and your
podcast was on some radio network
somewhere,
you'd have to go to meetings,
weekly meetings with the studio.
He'd have some fucking program director,
some Dick.
Fuck asshole wants to tell you what to
talk about anymore.
Yeah.
Look,
you're losing.
You're losing sponsors.
I don't even have advertisers.
Good for you.
I do it.
I had him for awhile and I just got
tired of listening to myself talking
about underwear and shit.
So just do it for fun.
No,
no.
It's supported through patriot.
That's great to have people send me
money.
This is what I think ultimately I think
ultimately people will.
Someone's going to develop some sort of
an app thing where you can.
You can like have basically everything
you put out your podcast blogs,
although it would all be cut like a
channel,
you could even call it channel and that
would be like a new social media
platform that you could do everything
from,
you know,
and people could either sign up for it
and pay for it or not,
you know,
that's how Sam Harris has it.
You can either pay for his podcast or
not.
That's how you have it too,
right?
Yeah.
Although you get it for free.
You get it for free.
So if you want to support,
if you want to support it.
Okay.
You pay and I do some,
uh,
some bonus stuff for Patriana only.
Yeah.
Sam does.
It could be a buck a month,
you know?
Yeah.
Why not?
And I think there's,
the future's probably going to be
something like that.
That's the present,
as you said.
I mean,
Sam's doing it.
Dunkin's got a Patriot on thing.
I do.
You got to get a Patriot on Joe.
No,
I make some money.
I make plenty of money with ads.
I don't.
I'm trying to think of like what.
It's almost like give the option if you
pay,
you get no ads or a free.
A lot of people do that.
That's good.
Dan Savage does that.
He has the.
I forget what it's called,
but yeah,
there's the ad free version and the.
That's probably a good month,
if that makes sense,
because that way if you don't want to
pay for it,
you don't have to,
but the point being that you can reach a
whole lot of people,
forget about paying.
You can reach a whole lot of people and
get ideas to a whole lot of people that
you could just never reached before.
No one would let you.
Why would anybody invest in you?
Why would they even put that time in and
then you're going to keep all of it a
lot.
No Way.
When you think about publishing now,
right?
I write a book that bill comes out.
Somebody buys a copy of sex at dawn.
Right now in paperback,
I get eight point two,
five percent of the.
Of the price.
That's minus 15 percent of that.
That goes to my agent and then taxes.
That's Hilarious,
right?
I mean a pimp,
let's a hooker keep 50 percent of the
money.
Wow.
A stingy pam.
What is a gate lady like?
J Dot k dot rowling's when she's balling
on top of the world kind of deal as she
get.
What depends what she signed,
you know,
but I mean she's already like Stephen
King.
People that occur,
they can cut a totally different deal,
but the standard contract is what I had,
which was,
you know,
eight percent on hard copy.
It's eight percent for 5,000
copies,
then 10 percent,
5,012
percent after that in hard copy.
And then paper bag is eight point two,
five percent forever.
How many books have you sold in America?
Maybe $400,000.
Four hundred 50,000,
something like that.
It's a lot of books.
Not really.
I mean it's 20 languages.
That's what's cool.
It's worldwide filled with 400,000.
It's a lot of books.
If you look at it that way,
that's how you have to learn what it
really is.
But in terms of money,
it's not that much money,
especially if you,
you know,
stretch it out over the years it took to
write it and all the promotion and all
that.
It's not a way to make a lot of money
writing books.
Even it used to be,
if you had a New York Times bestseller
back in the day,
you've made a lot of money really.
But the reading audience is much smaller
now than it was 20,
30 years ago.
What about books on cassette or audio?
That's a different deal.
You signed a deal generally with
audible,
they sort of own that market which is an
Amazon company,
right?
And uh,
yeah,
you get,
I forget what the percentages,
but it's probably 18 to 20 something
like that.
And also,
um,
ebooks you get a slightly better deal.
I think you get 17 and a half percent of
the price of an Ebook,
which is funny though because it's not
costing the publisher anything
additional to have an Ebook,
it's already edited,
it's already the cover and all.
It's already done and there's no
distribution cost.
So you get 17 and a half percent as a
writer,
they get the rest.
That's so crazy.
There's no trucks,
there's no shelf,
there's no store,
no reason for them to be getting all
that money.
That's so crazy.
It's all gravy for them.
Yeah.
And it's not like they're recouping
costs and it used to be like back in
hemingway or whatever,
back in the day a publisher would,
would support an author through three,
four or five books,
thinking eventually something's going to
hit.
This guy has got talent eventually and
so it was an investment.
Now they expect you to have your own
platform,
your own access to media.
You sometimes they're asking authors to
hire their own editors,
their own publicists,
right?
Really?
Yeah.
But they still get all the money.
They still get the same contract that
the ratios are the same.
So it's like.
Yeah,
that's why I say it's like a napster
kind of thing.
It's at the point now where it's like,
wait a minute,
if I got a platform,
I got access to media,
I'm hiring my own editor.
Why?
Why am I giving you creative control?
And Ninety two percent of the fucking
revenue.
It's a strange business.
That is a strange business.
Now essentially what they have is
credibility.
So if you self publish or publish with
some independent publisher,
The New York Times isn't going to review
it or won't know.
Wow.
Because it's a very insular world.
Well that's crazy.
If it's a book that takes off,
then a publisher will come in and buy.
So like 50 shades of gray.
That was self published.
I wonder why.
Yeah.
But look what happens.
They found they tapped into a market.
A chick that let's get spit on.
Right.
There are a lot of them.
There's a lot of them,
I don't know about their hood on,
but certainly joked.
Yeah.
Smacked around by a billionaire.
Good looking good looking guy with a
heart of gold.
Gold.
But it likes to spit in your mouth.
Yeah.
And then she.
And then ultimately he'll see the light
and of course he'll be taking course.
That's fantasy.
That's the fairy tale.
That's what everybody wants.
So you.
That's why I was saying earlier,
I've got this idea,
I was talking to Duncan about this the
other night.
I've got this idea to write an erotic
memoir,
but that'll sort of be like my last book
because at that point I'll have burned
all the bridges.
You'll be the only person who would ever
interviewed me after that.
I think I was planning for it to come
out around my 60th birthday and it it'll
be called an old manifesto.
It just changed the names of people.
Oh No.
I'm not worried about the people.
I'm not gonna hurt anybody in the bush
or it's more just about.
You know,
when people you fucked and people find
out the truth.
Dude,
you're gonna become legendary.
But it's true though,
but it's not a book about how much I got
laid.
It's not.
It's not a book about how cool I am.
It's a book about the amazing things
I've learned in sexual situations and
that the world is so different from what
people think.
How so?
There's just so many things going on
that mainstream people can't imagine.
Like,
I mean,
I was in college the first time a man
told me he would be happy for me to have
sex with his wife and it wasn't a Kinky,
weird thing.
It was like,
I'm not doing it.
She's wonderful.
I noticed that you guys like each other.
I just want you to know it's cool with
me.
Wow.
That's the first time since then there's
probably been,
I don't know,
half
a dozen or something.
Um,
mothers like,
would you please have sex with my
daughter?
She is,
she really,
you know,
there is a good one.
Generally it's because she didn't like
the boyfriend always.
Yeah.
So I was like,
well,
you show my daughter.
Like there's a world out there that she
doesn't know about.
Yeah,
there's always that.
But then they recruit you and you got to
take on the project.
Well,
you know,
should you choose to accept it?
Should you choose to accept it?
They expect you to stick around as well.
Not necessarily just the world's weird
stuff that people think like,
oh my God,
if you know you have sex with someone's
wife and he knows he's going to kill
you,
well maybe not.
Maybe it'll take you out for a beer
afterwards and you'll be friends.
This is the subject of Arusha fears
podcast this week with our,
uh,
with Aubrey Marcus and they're talking
about open relationships and they get
uber honest.
It's very intense.
I think that we live and cultural
patterns and that what we see around us,
we replicate.
I think there's a lot of evidence for
that.
If you just pay attention,
forget about studies,
just to look at how different people are
in other parts of the world.
People that are putting plates in their
lips and rings through their noses.
People that the way people tattoo
themselves,
the way people express themselves in
dance,
like human beings vary so wildly and
what we accept when we don't accept.
I was going to bring up Japan earlier.
It's one of the more fascinating travel
experiences I've had was going to Japan
because when you go to Tokyo you realize
like this is a completely different way
of living.
Like they have a completely different
way of interacting on the streets.
They have a completely different way
that they have decorated their buildings
completely.
Like I have tattoos.
They told me I had to wear long sleeves
at the gym.
I had to go back and change my shirt.
They don't accept expose tattoo
associated with organized crime,
so I had to go back and just.
There's a lot of that like where you
realize like this is a totally different
way of living,
but if I lived there I would live like
these people.
So the.
The momentum of these patterns in these
cultures gets established and then it
takes something radical to lift them and
to free people from these patterns and
once they're free from these patterns,
then they have a real opportunity to
objectively assess the way they behave
and whether or not this is the way they
want to behave or the way they want to
live or whether that just expect it to
because of this unthinking culture.
Momentum.
Think that's what podcasts is doing.
The,
the,
the big thing with podcasts is that it's
creating more narratives and it's
creating more discussions about
interesting subjects and more questions
and discussions about like why we live
our life a certain way.
And if you live a regular life with
regular people,
what are the odds that you get a chance
to sit down with a guy like you for
three hours or a guy like Graham Hancock
or go like,
you know,
fill in the blank.
Well,
the fascinating people that you are.
I have talked to in our podcasts and
then do these conversations get right in
someone's head.
Whether their earbuds on,
whether at work typing some nonsense
bullshit into some fucking forms they
have to fill out because that's what
they do for a living.
That's what's different and that's never
happened before.
These I like no generation before.
The podcast generation had that option.
You had Howard Stern,
you had and it was always funny.
You had art.
Bell was always weird and then you had
all the right wing Wacko dudes on am
talk radio.
The Michael Savages,
you know the fucking rush limbaugh and
you had all those people but you didn't.
Yeah.
You didn't have a guy who just talks
about whatever he wants to talk about.
You had to be like,
well,
Chris,
before we give you this radio broadcast
show what kind of a show you're going to
do?
You're going to do a left wing show.
You're going to do a show on cooking.
What are you going to do?
Now?
I'm going to talk about sex and tribes
and about how I think monogamy is just
a.
it's just a cultural construct and
really the way we evolved like,
Whoa,
you fucking hippie.
There's no money in that,
like before you came to someone and
said,
hey,
I'm going to write this book and it's
going to sell about 400,000
copies and it's basically same.
Monogamy is bullshit.
What are you think?
They'd be like,
what the Fuck Outta here?
No one's going to buy that.
Everybody wants to be monogamous and
have a picket fence and live in the same
row of houses where everybody looks the
same.
Everybody's got this.
Oh you have an in ground pool.
You lucky bastard.
You know the,
what,
what podcasts have done is expose why we
accept things as fact and why we just
chew it because everybody around us does
it.
We are such a massive product of our
environment.
You know,
and I think when we were talking earlier
about race and about race being a
determining factor for ICU,
like you don't really ever know.
You might know from studies,
but you don't know until those people
who have the high Iq have to live the
lives of the people that had the low Iq
and they have to have the same
environment that they grow up.
And the same fears and the same
influences,
negative and positive,
then you'll know.
And even then you won't know because
there's so many determining factors
like,
you know,
I know people that are just way fucking
smarter than me.
They're just smarter.
I just know they are.
What is that?
I don't know.
Is it the amount of studying they've
done?
Is it the amount of knowledge they have?
Is that the path that they're on is
different than my path?
Or is it just their fucking brain works
better?
But also what do we mean by smarter?
You know,
I mean,
I look at someone like you.
Your discipline is a major factor in
your success.
So is that part of being smart?
It's smart enough to understand the
discipline as a worthwhile pursuit.
That's what it is.
So what
about someone who has a really high Iq
that's sitting in a basement eating lots
of ice cream and not doing what they
want to do?
That's not smart decision making for
sure.
Yeah.
But it's very high Iq,
right?
So what do we mean for a hunter gatherer
of these people in the Amazon?
We're talking about who can identify 500
different kinds of plants at a glance
and you know,
the behavior of animals and all this
stuff,
but you give them an Iq test and they're
like under 100 for sure.
Well,
I've had conversations with people that
are brilliant,
super brilliant people and science and
they'll try to explain to me mixed
martial arts and some fucked up
cockamamie Wayne.
I have to stop them.
Stop.
Okay.
Right now you sound like a fucking moron
and I know you're not a professor,
but you're talking about something that
I have a PhD,
I have a phd and people fucking people
up.
I understand it as good as anybody
that's ever lived.
So if you start talking nonsense about
how to fuck people up,
Oh,
your Kung Fu instructor said that,
oh fuck.
I like Aikido.
But I recognize that there's a lot of
bullshit.
There's a funding to practice.
I mean,
it's fun to be able to flip people
around like that and it would be a great
thing to know if you lived in feudal
Japan and you lost your sword and
someone was coming at you when you had
one chance at glory.
What I love about Aikido is how it
translates into psychological and
emotional stuff.
So what we were saying earlier about how
I don't engage with people who are
emotionally triggered by sex at dawn.
To me that's like,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I learned that kind of thing for my
Quito.
First of all,
you don't need to engage.
Secondly,
if you do engage,
what's important is that you stay calm
and centered and most of the time people
burn themselves out.
You don't even really need to.
As long as you step out of the way,
let people have what they need to have.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
But yeah,
as far as the fighting technique,
it's not what you're going to pull up in
the street.
It's not,
but it's just my point is that people
who are brilliant and are geniuses in
one aspect of life simply don't have
enough time to accumulate the same
amount of data about everything.
Just don't sure whether it's,
uh,
about,
you know,
fill in the blank clock making or
whatever the fuck it is.
There's just like,
there's things that people know that
you're,
you don't know and it doesn't make you
stupid.
It's just information.
The differences between how you apply
that information.
Like if you're a really smart person,
you don't do shit with it,
you're a moron.
You might be a really genius person,
but if your life is falling apart and
it's all because of your shitty
decisions and you've never tried to
improve upon your thought process and
just blame the whole world instead of
yourself,
you're a moron.
Even if you're really good at taking Iq
tests.
That's it.
I mean,
I don't personally,
I don't think that I'm particularly
intelligent.
I think that what I can do that a lot of
people don't do is think outside the box
and connect dots that other people
aren't connecting,
which is precisely because I didn't go
to the right schools and I,
you know,
in my twenties I went and fucked around
the world for 20 years.
You don't have tenure that you're
working for or anything that's going to
keep you in,
lie around and figure it out and I mean
that's the people that get stuck in
that.
Even intellectuals,
they get stuck in that trap of having to
toe the line in terms of like.
I mean,
good luck trying to find a conservative
professor.
Wright W,
four percent identify as conservatives
in mainstream universities and colleges
have some really ridiculously low
number,
might be 10 percent,
whatever it is,
but it's the vast minority.
You know,
if one,
if you get one out a 10,
you're super lucky.
I think that's
again,
what do we mean by conservative?
It's so confusing because the older I
get,
the more I realized that the language.
It's like one of those venn diagrams
where there's language and there's
reality and there's some overlap,
but there's a lot that doesn't
correspond,
you know,
I get into this a lot when people are
talking about homosexuality and whether
it's,
you know,
human nature or its culture or whatever,
and it's like,
first of all,
what do we mean by homosexuality?
I,
you,
and I've talked about this before,
this tribe in Papa New Guinea where the
boys suck as much dick as they can
because they think that semen contains
the essence of masculinity.
And so it's like,
to them that's not homosexual behavior,
that's normal male developmental
behavior and you know,
we,
we look at that and say,
oh well that's gay,
but they don't see it as gay.
So again,
it's,
as you were saying,
we replicate the behavior we see around
they have adult homosexuality or do they
only have sex with kids?
I think it's only at least the only kind
that's been reported by anthropologists
because again,
there's a filtering there,
of course is younger boys with older
boys.
So it's the younger boys are given blow
jobs to the older boys because that's
the way to get stronger and more
masculine scam.
Somebody pulled off one.
We have got no way of doing things with
my Dick.
He pulls the grass skirt aside.
Oh Shit.
Here we go.
Yeah.
It's drums sucking.
Dicks pump,
pump,
pump.
There you go.
It's pretty crazy though.
Again,
like what we were saying earlier that
you can have these pockets of culture
that they're radically different than
other places,
but the people just adapt and conform to
what's around them.
And I think that's the case with human
beings everywhere.
I don't think it's just the people that
live in New Guinea and it's not just the
people that live in the Congo or live in
woodland hills.
It's people that live everywhere.
It's just how human beings behave.
And it's also
interesting to look at how the culture
reflects the environment.
Yes.
Right.
And Marvin Harris wrote about this
cultural materialism,
how,
how a culture responds to an
environment,
sort of like how,
you know Cacti live in the desert.
There's a reason for that.
You put a cactus in the jungle that dies
immediately,
right?
It's adapted to an environment.
So you've got desert cultures,
right?
You've got jungle cultures,
so the culture actually grows in a way
that fits that ecological environment.
He,
he was the first.
I think he's the first person to figure
this out.
Certainly the first time I read it,
like some island,
some cultures are cannibalistic and
others aren't.
Right?
Why is that?
Like,
I'd never thought about it,
like why would the aztecs eat the,
their victims,
but the Christians didn't,
but the Christians killed a lot more.
They just left them to rot on the field.
Why is that?
Is that the Aztecs are particularly evil
or something?
I don't know.
Uh,
he applied this prism to it and show
that also in the South Pacific,
there are some islands that were,
the people are cannibalistic and other
islands where they weren't.
And so he looks at all these in when he
figured out was that in the places where
people are cannibalistic,
there are no domesticated animals that
eat different food than humans.
So for example,
you can't raise dogs for me because dogs
eat what we eat,
so it doesn't make sense.
But you can raise goats because goats
eat shit.
Humans don't eat right.
So in the places that are cannibalistic,
there was no nothing they could
domesticate for protein.
So when he killed a human yatim because
your protein starved.
Wow.
Isn't that crazy?
So it's an ecological thing.
The aztecs had no pigs,
right?
There was nothing they could
domesticate.
No cattle.
They had turkeys,
I think was the only time they had met
from a person they killed.
There were so psyched to not just going
to let it go.
Yeah.
They ever tell you that's the case with
bears.
The bears are all cannibals.
Cannibals.
It's really dark.
My friend Jonathan saw a bore,
a male bear kill a cub and then saw the
female eat it.
Oh,
the female,
the female chase the male way.
And after he'd killed that,
she was trying to eat it and she chased
him away and then she ate it.
Shader own cub.
And he said he had heard that they did
that before.
But watching that in person.
But they're all cannibal,
well,
lots of,
lots of mammal mothers will eat their
young.
But these guys come out of the den
looking for cubs.
The,
the spring bears,
they do it for two reasons.
They do it.
One,
they,
they know now that it's not just to try
to force the female and the Astros
again,
they used to think it was just that.
But now they like if you shoot a bear,
other bears will claim it as their since
start eating it and you have to chase
them off.
Like they're,
it's the world of a bear is so fucking
hard scrabble and so fraught with peril
and they have to,
you know,
you're talking about a 500 pound bear.
How much do you have to eat every day?
What do you have?
Do you like 30 pounds of meat or
something like moths and everything?
Their machines,
where they are is they clean the forest
up of babies.
They can't get away and any.
There's no overpopulating when there's
hikers.
Yeah.
Well they.
Oh that's so rare.
It's so rare and it's more black bears
in his brown bears.
When Brown bears kill people,
it's usually because someone fucked up
and came across a female with her babies
and the females want to take any
chances.
She fucks you up.
But when a blackberry too,
it's more likely for predation.
Also a black barrel chased up a tree.
A grizzly won't climb a tree.
Right?
That's true.
And a lot of times when the black bears
are near people,
the reason is because people have
encroached on their their areas and then
they started getting into eating garbage
and they start getting into eating
garbage.
They become a real problem because
they're smart and they realize like,
wow,
fucking chase after some deer when I
could eat this dude's trash.
And then how much does he does dude?
Like they don't.
They don't think about the problems with
that.
This is going to bring heat on the Klan,
you know,
they just fuck that person up.
I spent a lot of time thinking about
bears in Alaska.
You should.
Yeah,
I was working the first year.
It's so stupid.
I worked in this cannery in Kenai for
like six weeks.
Salmon,
Salmon.
Cannery.
Yeah.
And I was a 16 hours a day,
seven days a week,
just like full on,
fucking busting it out because the fish
are coming in and they got the lines
around it and you know,
um,
and at night I would go back and sleep
in my tent on this bluff where we were
all camped out.
And so,
like,
you know,
after six weeks everything smelled like
salmon,
everything,
my skin,
my hair,
my but everything.
And uh,
so after we left,
when I was with these two other dudes
and we were like,
let's go to Mckinley and like hike for
awhile and you know,
go in the.
And we're,
we hitchhiked,
we hitchhiked up to Denali and we were
walking back this dirt road and this,
this,
a ranger came along and his truck and he
stopped and he was this cool guy,
you know,
and he's like,
Hey,
you guys have been working?
Like,
yeah man.
It's like,
Yay.
Where he'd been working at Canada.
Yeah.
And what do you,
you're going to go hiking now,
like,
yeah,
yeah.
He said,
do you realize that every bear within 20
miles of here can smell it?
And you smell like food,
like,
oh yeah,
I hadn't thought about that.
Like getting the truck back.
I probably saved your life more than the
guy who saved you from the Scorpion and
gave you hepatitis.
Fucked me up,
man.
He did.
But the other guy really saved you.
Dude bears and fish.
Man.
That's a crazy combination.
And so the,
the big bears have.
Um,
cody cody.
I was out there.
That's the whole deal is that they're
just having fish each wales,
the whales
eat everything.
That's,
that is,
that's a bananas place to be,
man.
When you were going to 12 foot bears,
I worked on a boat the second year I
worked on a boat that was based at a
Kodiak.
Did you get to see a lot of them?
Yeah.
And around.
Oh Man,
I saw the bears.
I saw orchids.
I saw we were out in Prince William
Sound Orchestra,
the animal that I always point to that
if they didn't exist and there was a
legend of them,
it will be way more fascinating than
bigfoot.
If somebody told you that there's some
mammal that lives in the ocean and they
communicate with each other through a
complex series of sounds that we to this
day can't understand and that there are
several times they have accent.
They have accents.
Yeah.
They have dialects.
They leap through the air and smashed.
They stay.
Stay together and pods for life in a
very strong family bond if they didn't
exist.
If this was just like some big foot type
myth,
it would be way more interesting than
bigfoot is bigfoot dude just wanders
around the woods and it's because big
foot looks like a human.
Yeah.
You know,
so it's,
it's that wild.
It's the dog's fascinated by the wolf,
you know,
bright.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
That is exactly what it is.
That,
that could've been us.
We would.
You know about this genre of women who
read bigfoot erotic literature.
There's a lot of it.
Yeah.
You should write some jokes should.
That should be my move.
Maybe that's just what I really like.
You can't like.
I'll write a blurb for you for sure.
Yeah.
I blur the lines between erotica and
just like horrible hunting,
primal,
like slaughtering slaughtering of
villagers and then fucking the women.
Like it'd be like some weird murder
porn.
Like he would a storm into some weird
log cabin.
You do that.
He'll do that famous photo of you.
You know,
looking all bad ass and black and white.
That's the background for the author.
That's your author photo for sure.
Drinks way too much coffee and it's
getting me wet.
Just thinking about it.
Wow.
You get wet.
Fifty six years old.
Joe Got a little leakage by the way.
Last week.
Big,
big event in my life.
What have first prostate exam bitches.
Oh,
how was that?
It was fabulous.
Did it feel good?
No,
no,
but.
But everything.
You look very healthy.
Can I just say that right now?
You look at and help.
Last time I saw you,
you and me and Duncan were here maybe
three months ago.
There was a moment.
We're talking about something and you
said,
you know,
go into yoga two days a week,
can change your life,
and you looked at me and I don't know
that,
that this was happening on your end,
but in my end it felt significant.
It was Chris,
Chris,
you know,
just two yoga classes a week and change
your life.
And I started going to yoga and I feel
much better.
Oh,
look at that.
That's why you're all healthy looking
that in my,
uh,
my urologist.
So I got to tell you about this
urologist though.
Okay.
Super Cool Guy.
What'd you give him?
Four stars on Yelp.
I give him five.
Yeah.
Uh,
and in fact I've on beyond my podcast.
Oh Wow.
But he's hesitant to do it and I
understand why he works for a big
hospital and you know,
he doesn't want to become a rock star,
but we ended up hanging out in his
office talking about this dude gave
himself have a sec dummy.
Oh,
he's.
He told me,
he's like,
that's how bad he didn't want to have
kids.
He pried his dick hole open delay.
He was just like,
you know,
I do it,
I've done it.
A lot of them,
I want to see what I could do it,
and he said,
Yo,
my wife wasn't into the idea,
but she insisted that I have a colleague
standing by in case I got into trouble,
so that made sense.
I did a guy who was going a little to
the left to the left himself,
fucking vasectomy.
That is the most bad ass thing I think
I've ever heard.
Did he like what did he do with his
feet?
I don't know the position back here,
way back contortionists and just digging
in and he said,
it's on this side of the scrotum.
Maybe yours,
Bro,
not mine.
Oh,
you got yours.
But that's what they will be proud of.
I get the.
They told me I had the biggest pipe.
Well,
this data,
they did tie my tubes.
They said my never saw tubes like my.
He said to me afterwards,
he said,
you got the prostate.
Have a 20 year old.
I love you brother.
That's good.
That's good to hear.
Yeah,
it was really funny.
Where are you fixed?
No,
you're not.
You're still shooting live loads.
Who knows?
Who knows how alive they are at this
point.
Now you got defects in your loads.
Yeah.
You get older,
you get defects,
right?
Yeah.
So do you really do look healthier?
I'm not bullshitting.
I saw that like instantly,
so two yoga classes a day or a week or a
week day of crazy,
but we come in here to make it,
but to a week really can change your
life.
Yeah,
and I'm doing the like old lady classes
to those old ladies are tough as fuck.
That's how they got to be old ladies
dude.
Like plank position.
I'm like,
lady,
come on,
my arms are shaking.
There's some old ladies in my class at
humbled me.
I take these old ladies,
old housewives and they're fucking tough
as shit and they're in there everyday.
I come there a couple days a week and
they look at me like,
oh,
decided to drop in.
So I had to cut every day.
Every day you see their progress to
especially.
It's very impressive to me when you see
flexibility,
progress and old people and you realize
like most of what we take for decide
like,
oh,
this is how far your body should move
when you're 60 or this is how your body
should move your 70 space in the average
person who doesn't do a goddamn thing
with their body.
They don't grow up thinking you don't
eat right.
Again,
it's based on what you see around you.
In Spain,
everybody goes for a walk after dinner,
you can be 90 years old.
They're out there walking in after the
way to go to.
It's nice if you go to a place,
it feels good to have a meal and walk
around.
That's why it's like you ever eaten
Malibu.
There's a Malibu seafood.
Do you ever see that?
You know that place,
right?
Right on that little PCA.
Yeah.
Eat outside is really good and have
fresh seafood there all the time.
About the real in.
No,
no,
no.
I think it's called Malibu seafood.
That's what it's called,
but anyway,
the problem is getting across the pch.
You got to get across pch says death
defying.
Oh,
you park on one side and ran across.
Yeah,
that's across.
Especially with little kids.
That's fucking scared.
She'd go to the real end.
It's on the pch down near to paying.
I've heard.
That's good.
It is good.
And they've got tables outside.
You can bring a dog and they kind of
picnic tables.
Anyway,
we talk about this after.
Yeah,
but there's something about.
There's another restaurant in Malibu
too.
That's a really good spot.
It's like right on the beach and you can
eat and then just go walk and it's like
walking on the beach or just going for a
walk like right after a meal.
That's what everybody's supposed to do.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
Yeah.
It helps digestion and when you live in
a,
you know,
I saw this so much in Spain.
When you live in a culture that's
healthy,
you're healthy.
You know what my favorite example is?
Boulder,
Colorado.
You go to boulder,
everybody's got fucking Patagonia
jackets on.
They're running up hills and dirt bike
riding.
There's a yoga place every corner and
people are having fun.
Having a good to not work.
No,
it's fun.
It bulb exercise is fun.
That's what people don't understand.
It's really an,
it's not fun to be unhealthy and when
you try to exercise,
when you're unhealthy,
it feels like shit because your body
feels like shit.
But once you get the dust knocked off of
it and get it moving.
And I'm not talking about crossfit or
fucking mma training or Jujitsu,
I'm just talking about any kind of
exercise.
Just get that blood flow and you'll be,
uh,
you'll be a better version of you.
I got a bike.
I don't know if you don't have talked
about this.
It's this electric assist.
A mountain bike.
Oh yeah.
My friend John Dudley has those made so
much fun.
Yeah.
And where I live it's like uphill to get
to any of the fire roads.
So a normal bike.
I'm just not going to do it because it's
like a half hour of hell to get any real
interesting.
But this thing it,
it only assists when you pedal.
Now there's no throttle or anything.
A specialized gave it to me because I
had this dude on my podcast who is,
I'm a professional mountain bike racer,
and he was like,
dude,
you got to get a bike here in Topanga.
This is heaven here.
And I was like,
yeah,
but like that's where I would ride,
you know,
way the fuck up there.
And he's like,
yeah,
let me talk to some people.
Well my buddy John Dudley uses those for
deer hunting because when you walk on
the ground,
well not just that when you walk on the
ground,
you leave,
sent a.
So instead of doing that,
he rides a bike.
So when you ride a bike,
you're just like deers.
Nose is so much stronger and more
powerful than ours that if the wind is
at your back and the deers in front of
you,
you're fucked.
You're fucked.
But if you play the wind correctly,
one of the best ways to avoid leaving
scent of a deer passes by after you've
been there is to ride a bike.
But you don't want to ride a bike and
exert yourself because then you'll be
sweaty and you have to sit in a tree
stand.
You'll freeze your fucking ass off.
So instead he has these electric assist
bikes and they're fucking amazing.
And when I was in Iowa,
we took these suckers out into the woods
bond.
It's amazing.
Like easy pill,
doesn't matter,
just rode up the hill.
No problem.
Yeah,
it's still an effort,
but it's not like you don't.
It's just like a light walk.
They're awesome.
I took it out to Utah.
I was out in the van scarlet to Vanson
and I were out in a canyon lands.
That's so nice,
man.
That's so pretty.
And there was this one ride,
it was like 20 miles I think out on this
jeep track,
like you could never go on.
I mean even in a jeep,
a serious four wheel drive,
you're going two miles an hour instead
of these.
But on this bike,
just just cruise and 20 miles out to
where the Colorado and the Green River
converge.
It's this canyon.
Nobody out there.
And I'm just cruising.
It's like riding a horse.
It's so cool.
Well,
I did think at one point when I was
going through this field with tall
grasses that I,
to a cougar,
I would have looked like impossible to
resist.
Yeah.
Maybe top speeds.
Twenty miles an hour.
So it would have gotten me.
Most cougars are not really into
attacking people,
but they have attack people on mountain
bikes before.
Sure.
Yeah.
I think it's like a yarn thing,
like a ball of yarn.
Kitten just can't help it.
Well,
you've got cats,
right?
Yeah.
I somehow,
I,
I feel like cats are similar enough that
if I saw a cougar,
I wouldn't know how to deal with it just
because I know cats.
Man.
You can look in bluff a cat.
Do you see the video I posted up today
where a guy in boulder,
so for fucking mountain lions on a
street for together with family,
it was the big ones for full grown
fucking man,
not a mother.
And yet they don't hang together.
Taro,
not according to this fucking video.
Go full screen and freak us out,
Jamie or not.
Yeah,
but there's two sides.
Look at that.
Two big ass grown ass mountain lions,
and then they go down the street.
Look,
what do we have at the end of the road?
Oh,
another big ass grown ass mountain lion.
And another one line on.
It's back over there.
Wow.
Imagine turning that corner and you're
fucking electric bikes road during the
fucking road.
So this guy,
this is his house.
This guy's looking out of his house.
He's outside of Boulder Mountain lions.
Don't give a shit.
That's where I'm a mountain.
Lion ate my dog and boulder.
Really?
Dogs all the time.
They get them.
They hang around near your house.
They start targeting your dogs.
It's easy.
Prey.
Got Eaten by a lion.
A real the African lion.
Oh Shit.
That's,
that's more scary.
Yeah,
it's Africa.
Fuck.
What kind of dog was it?
Was a small Pomeranian American eskimo
mix.
Sweet out of a dog.
He was a great dog.
Worse ways to go.
Yeah.
Look,
there's just some out there,
man.
Between the bears and the dogs or the
cats and also the foxes.
Foxes are amazing.
I mean,
I love foxes.
I think they're really interesting
animals and they're one of the few
animals in the wild that will,
if you live in a certain area for long
enough,
they will almost become domesticated,
like they get close to you and hang out
with you and you could feed them and
they'll,
they'll walk with you and hang out with
you.
Like real close by.
There are weird animal.
They're not quite a wolf and they're not
like a coyote like a Fox.
Our relationship with Fox is,
is very playful,
you know?
Have you ever seen a grizzly man?
Remember his relationship with the Fox,
hung around the campsite or something.
Took his hat,
stole his,
had ran away and they were playing.
The Fox used to sit on his tent and he'd
be right there and be like,
how are you?
Good morning today.
I like that.
They would just hang with them and walk
with them.
There's that lady sue Akins who lives.
She lives 200 plus miles above the
arctic circle.
She's on that show.
Life below zero.
There it is.
There's the grizzly man,
like,
look at this fucking animal just hanging
with him,
man.
I mean,
it's an odd way the fuck out the way the
fuck out.
But once they get accustomed to you,
they're very intelligent and they
realized like,
this guy's not going to hurt me.
And then they become like your little
buddy and if you give them food,
I mean,
this is essentially how animals got
domesticated,
right?
Right.
This is how wolves became dogs.
They just hung around with us long
enough that when they were outside the
edge of the campfire and we gave them
food to keep them from attacking us or
whatever.
But Fox is,
and in particular,
they'll kill the shit out of your cat,
but kill your dog.
Foxes will kill a lot of things to kill
a lot of fonts.
You know,
it's,
I,
I saw um,
a fox on,
on the Internet with a font that was
almost as big as its body and it was
dragging this font across this,
uh,
this road.
And I was like,
oh,
I never thought it would kill something
that big.
I would thought they'd get rats like,
well they do generally right environment
or not marmots moles and stuff.
You'll see the,
how they jump.
They hear so well they can located under
the snow.
And Jana.
Well here's how fucked up.
I had a coyote killed one of my chickens
recently and I buried the chicken and
um,
I was in the yard the other day.
I heard this noise and my golden
retriever who has zero killer instinct.
I mean he'll,
he'll kill a bird or something.
He gets a hold of it,
but he's not like a guard dog.
He's a sweetie and he's,
he's like,
what is going on over there?
And these communities are on the roof of
the fucking henhouse trying to pry away
the chicken wire.
And I hear this clink clink clink clink
is the kylies biting the chicken wire
trying to break it open and get into the
chickens.
So they killed one chicken.
I chased him off.
I got a video over there.
I was going to post their bills.
Like,
this is too gross chicken.
They got fucked up by this code is plus.
It's sad.
I love those chickens,
they're like a pet,
you know,
so I dug a whole bird,
the chicken and the coyote.
He dunked the fucking hole up and found
chicken and it was a couple feet down.
You know,
it wasn't a super shallow grave.
I mean that coyote smelled that chicken
through two feet of dirt and went and
dug it out.
I went out there a couple days later and
I was like,
where's the fucking chicken?
There's just a hole there.
I was like,
Whoa,
this is crazy.
They could smell through the dirt,
man.
They knew the chicken was down there.
It's crazy.
That's crazy.
Do you ever have strange experience with
wild animals while you were tripping?
Never have zero experience with animals
while tripping a lot.
Cause I tripped in the woods alone.
Yeah,
man,
I know too much about the words.
I want a trip inside of arm compound.
Well that'll be safe.
Loaded guns nearby.
A fear fetish.
No,
almost joking.
Around half of it is for entertainment.
I've gotten.
I've done mushrooms in a field before.
It didn't freak me out.
A baseball field when Aubrey and I went
bear hunting,
he took mushrooms one of the days I
didn't.
I wasn't with him.
You know,
when you go to your own little area of
the woods by yourself,
I find it hard to shoot anything.
If I were tripping,
you wouldn't.
If you were hungry.
The thing about those things is like,
bear hunting is a weird one man,
because they need to control the
populations because if they don't
control the populations,
the bears decimate the moose and the
deer and they eat 50 percent of the Fonz
as it is,
right.
If,
uh,
if,
although deer populations out of
control,
a lot of places,
not,
not in Alberta have Pennsylvania,
it's a,
it's a healthy balance,
but it's only apparently a healthy
balance according to biologists.
And it's not according to vegans are
hunters,
but according to biologist,
it's only healthy if the bear population
is kept to a certain number.
If it gets too crazy,
then they run out of food and then
there's a lot of cannibalism already,
but then it gets even worse and you
know,
then they start encroaching on cities
and towns and it gets.
It gets weird,
but are they treated it in terms of like
a number thing instead of looking at it
from a moral standpoint like should you
kill an animal?
They.
They're like,
well,
if you don't kill an animal,
this animal is overbalanced this,
that overpopulated,
this animal's going to be under
populated now because they're going to
go after them.
They get to kill a disproportionate
number of them,
so they try to keep this so.
But bears are apex predators.
So who was killing bears?
Other bears,
grizzlies.
So then the sort of the ultimate balance
is to just leave the bears and let the
other bears kill him.
That's a good balance.
But then you're living in a world where
you have 11 foot 12 foot grizzlies
everywhere you go wandering into town.
If you live in a place like Alberta in
some,
some areas of Alberta,
you have know good population of elk and
Moose and deer,
well that means you're gonna have a good
population of monsters,
so if you're comfortable with that,
you just have to decide how much risk do
you want to have.
Because once the bears chew through
them,
they're going to go after you.
You should,
uh,
Boris with the bow.
Yeah,
I've done that.
Yeah.
A friend of mine invited me to go,
uh,
do that in Hawaii.
Hawaii has to do it.
It's a good place because of that I
don't have any predators.
And they fuck up.
And he was explaining that the boers
fuck up the coral reefs because they dig
up all the dirt and then it runs off in
the rain and it contaminates the bays
are.
That makes sense?
Yeah.
So it's a really big thing in Hawaii
that they have to really go after the
bars as much as there's a project right
now in Maui where they,
they're going to fence in an area and
the area that they're fenced in,
they have to.
It's like 5,000
acres,
I think it is,
where they have to eradicate the deer
that are in this one particular area
because they're trying to reclaim the
forest land and a lot of these deer,
the deer,
most of the large mammals in Hawaii are
not native and so these invasive species
is access.
Deer from Asia actually are just,
they eat everything.
Nothing gets to grow,
like just getting not going to be a
forest because the little things grow
and they just eat them,
eat them right when they're coming up
and they just.
There's so many of them,
so they also have a problem with people
needing food,
so what they're doing is they're like,
they have this project where they're
going out and they're hunting these
animals,
killing them and giving these food to
people for free and so they've set it up
like this.
So they have a real sustainable food
source for all these poor people,
which is the best meat in the world.
So delicious.
I was going to say much better than
industrial.
Sure.
Shit.
It's really good.
I mean,
even in terms of wild game animals,
they have the most delicious game
animal,
like two thoughts.
It's usually,
it's either elk or access deer.
Those are the two to go back and forth.
I've had both.
They're both amazing.
But access to your are fucking
everywhere.
Never had bison.
You must have.
Yes.
Yeah,
that's,
that's.
Yeah,
free.
Amazing.
It's amazing.
Cool animal to see in a while.
You have a star wars around.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
We saw them in yellowstone.
Big Herd of.
I'm just chilling,
but it was weird because they were so
accustomed to people to just lounge in
like 100 yards from folks.
Can you imagine like before they shot
them all that oceans of those things.
Crazy.
Know where that came from.
That's another one.
That's a weird one that I didn't know.
Dan Flores is a fascinating guy.
He wrote a book,
a great book and coyotes called Coyote
America,
but he wrote a,
um,
a pete.
It was a paper,
a bison,
diplomacy.
Bison ecology.
That's the name of it.
But it's basically saying that what
happened was when the Europeans came to
America and the European spread disease,
it decimated the native American
population by as much as 90 percent.
That is when the bison boom happened.
Bison ecology and bison diplomacy.
The southern plains from 1800 1850.
So what his,
what his take is that the overpopulation
of Bison was a direct result of these
native American people being decimated
because their population dropped by 90
percent.
No one was hunting the buffalo.
So the buffalo just
went crazy.
And there's with no hunters chasing
after him.
One,
two,
three decades later,
you've got a shit ton of Bison says
running around everywhere.
And he points to early settlers that
described in great detail all of the
various game animals that they came
across.
But nerium mentioned of the Bison and
certainly not a mention of like these
gigantic million strong herds of bison
roaming the plains.
Anything that's a direct result of all
of their predators,
the native Americans who had got really
good hunting them and even even surplus,
letting them where they drive them off
cliffs and just take what they could.
That was at the bottom.
Although it's also interesting to think
how the introduction of horses would
have changed everything.
Horses and guns.
What Dan Flores says that is that just
with this,
with why,
just forget about European settlers.
Just the native Americans with horses
and rifles were on their way to extra
painting the by the Bison.
Yeah.
Crazy.
So we,
I mean,
this does not exonerate all the
Europeans that had the stacks of bones
and that killed them in mass.
They certainly did that.
There's no doubt about it.
And that's what almost caused the,
uh,
the complete extinction.
That's it.
It was at the end.
It was the Europeans.
It was us,
the settlers to starve out the Indians.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
it wasn't even.
That is,
that's another thing that they think
that there was not a concerted effort to
starve about the Indians.
They wanted it for search for food.
They wanted the tongues.
What I read is the Buffalo Bill and
those dudes were shooting them and just
leaving the bodies out there.
It was to wipe out the Lakota because
they couldn't fucking beat the Lakota.
That might've been done as well,
but that's not.
That's not what.
What killed them off.
I mean when you see these giant stacks
of skulls,
they were doing that for using them as a
commodity.
A lot of it was just for their tongues,
believe it or not.
Their tongues were very valuable,
valuable delicacy,
and then it was for their skins and you
know when they.
They had meat hunting.
They had what they called market hunting
where they take guys who came back from
the war and they were looking for a job,
but one of the best jobs and get,
are you good shot?
Great.
You can be a hunter,
and they would go and shoot fucking
everything.
Everything that moved and they wiped out
all the antelope,
elk,
all the.
It wasn't just the bison,
it's just the bison is such an iconic
thing and then obviously those piles of
skulls,
it was unusual.
The amount of effort they put into
killing them,
but I don't think it was necessarily
just to just to wipe out them so that
the native Americans would star.
I'm sure they did that locally and bury
my heart at wounded knee.
No,
I don't think I did.
It's a beautiful book.
It's really interesting book about the
sort of final chapter of different
tribes in North America,
Jeronimo and the Apaches and sitting
bull and all these people and it's just
really interesting the story of the sort
of contact and the characters and the
different things that happen.
Yeah.
I
read that when I was very young when I
was running around in a loin cloth,
throwing apples at rabbits.
That is,
if you look at human history,
what is this here?
They used to shoot them from.
From.
From trains.
Yeah.
They did it for fun too.
Crazy.
Yeah.
There were so many of them.
They just thought they could just shoot
them.
What else?
What our relationship with the natural
world that represents,
you know,
well this is what I was going to say is
like,
has there ever been anything like that
other than I mean anything in terms of
the impact of a group of people landing
on a continent like nothing that we've
ever observed,
so the greatest mortality in history for
sure and did great.
It's changed to like not only that but
this weird movement to the west and like
landing landing on this weird continent
that was filled with these people that
lived in a completely different way.
I mean,
what are the odds that you're going to
get to a place you think of where Europe
was in the 17 hundreds,
the 14 hundreds,
you know,
when the first started arriving and
think of the sophistication with the
boats and the written language and all
the different things,
and then they show up,
go across the ocean and land to a place
that has zero cities.
No,
there were cities to.
The land was.
Was bigger than almost all European
cities.
When Cortez walked into it,
that's in Mexico.
That's where the Aztecs were.
They also had sewage and lit streets.
They did more in South America and North
America,
right?
Yeah.
No,
nor from.
I mean,
you're talking about America,
Canada.
There was nothing comparable at that
point,
but that's what I meant.
I mean,
like when they're landing here and they
made their way all the way to
California,
they're not encountering a single city.
Right?
I mean,
that's just fucking bananas.
You've got thousands of miles of just
natural people living in tents.
Yeah,
no,
crazy.
Do you ever sleep in a teepee?
Now this place in Terlingua stating the
teepee.
Jeff Microbiology Guy,
he's got a bunch of,
or microbiome guy.
He's got a bunch of teepees.
They like luxury,
beautiful teepees,
luxury teepees.
Fucking gray.
That's a luxury tp,
uh,
Jamie base.
Camp Terlingua.
You'll see fucking beautiful base camp
and Terlingua t e R L I n g u a
Terlingua.
It's uh,
yeah,
they're,
they're fucking sweet there.
They've got like a concrete base and
maybe a three foot wall around it.
And then the teepees on top so the wind
doesn't blow around.
And then he showed me the design of tbs
is really interesting.
It's like they're designed so the wind
comes under the teepee,
have that dope.
They rent those out.
Yeah.
Oh,
this is crazy.
We offer once of a kind one of a kind
experience without massive 26 foot tp
over the top of a sunken Kiva.
What's a Kiva?
Kiva is like a Hopi dwelling that's semi
submerged.
Each of our three luxury hold each of
three luxury.
TPS has a comfy,
comfy king size bed.
Fold out couch.
Plenty of seating rubs throughout.
Sink under counter fridge.
Keurig coffee maker,
the microwave.
Microwave popcorn outdoor fire pit,
I think outdoors.
One word there,
isn't it?
And house a private bath.
House private.
Hey Jeff,
get with the CISO mountains.
It's a beautiful area.
Is it?
Looks like it,
man.
That looks bad ass.
Nice.
Wow.
I slept in both of those.
That's cool.
One hundred year old.
Hold on Jim.
A rebuilt this rule.
One hundred year old.
Ruined.
Located in the heart of Terlingua ghost
town.
Wow,
that's amazing too.
We gotta wrap this up,
right?
I got to Piss on your source.
I'm sure you do.
Tangentially reading.
It's out now.
Anybody can get it everywhere,
all the places that they sell books and
of course tangentially speaking places
you get podcasts is this,
man.
I'm glad you did this.
I'm glad you became a podcast guy.
The podcast world is richer for it.
Well,
thank you.
I appreciate it.
I'm richer for it.
Thanks to you and Duncan,
Chris,
Ryan motherfuckers.
See you guys tomorrow.
Bye.